you
okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel and
welcome to the pre-game
uh before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos as you
guys know if you have watched two or
more of my lives and you do not
subscribe we have what beef okay
beef i'm like super tough so don't
um okay and don't forget to turn on your
notifications because every
wednesday thursday and saturday we do
live shows straight out of my apartment
and if you want to be notified when
we're live
make sure you turn on your notifications
also before i start our sponsor is
cooking with chris so chris offers
completely customizable meal plans i'm
down 15 pounds on this meal plan guys
like i promise you this is the best
you're ever going to feel in your life
jessica did i not play a lot better the
last month
yeah and it was because
nobody was because i was eating better
like seriously like even like mentally
you just feel a lot better
okay so
now that i'm done with my intro
um we have some special guests today and
why don't you guys say your name your
age
your relationship status
and
tell me where you're from
me first yes uh sarah gaby is my name
uh
my age is 40. my relationship status is
single
and i'm from the uk i'm from london
what's up y'all you've seen me before
uh i'm jessica i'm 23 currently single
and i
am from new jersey
i'm kirsty i'm 34 and i'm from the
original jersey
okay
my name's innie i am
38 years old i had to remember that one
the other thing
as well i'm the only one that's married
on this show and i'm from the uk
okay so have you guys heard of
so the topic today is courtney taylor
and her boyfriend christian
have you guys heard of this case at all
briefly she killed him
yes
i read the title and then didn't go
further than that yet
another one
um so basically courtney taylor is an
only fans model in miami
and she's hot i'm not gonna lie to you
like one to ten i would give her like a
solid ten like she's fine
and she's dating this guy named
christian okay
and
christian and her um seemingly are the
perfect couple on instagram but you guys
know how that is
yes so
seemingly the perfect couple
and then one day the police are called
to their apartment
and he has been stabbed by her
and he actually was taken to the
hospital and he he's bled to death he
died
stop just the ones
i believe it was once i'm not actually
let me know in the comments guys if i
got that wrong
but
um i think he was stabbed once like in
the shoulder and he bled to death so she
hit a major artery or something yeah
something like that yeah um
and now the evidence that's coming out
on this case is a little bit mixed
so the
neighbors said they have seen
him hit her
and that it was a domestic violence case
okay
um however
the friends said they'd seen her hit him
right
and they said he they'd never seen him
hit her and there was accounts of him
like sleeping in
i don't know like different parts of the
building
um basically
like so she like kicked him out yeah
something like that like it was
basically like there was some accounts
that it was kind of a toxic relationship
right
so when the police get there she
threatens to kill herself
and they bring her to a psych ward
okay
she gets out of the psych ward she gets
eight thousand dollars bail
for killing someone
that's some female white privilege there
[Music]
what if i kill my girlfriend if i get
eight thousand dollars bail
that's what
that's how i feel um but
um basically she's claiming it was
domestic violence and she did it in
self-defense
[Music]
um however the friends and family say he
would never do something like this right
but the neighbors say
but we've seen him attack her
now it gets even weirder because
after she gets out of the mental
institution
people start digging into her
she has a lot of duis and she also went
on this podcast in miami and was just
kind of like wild and on there like she
was saying i only f like rich black guys
like
yeah yeah
so she's got a type
all right it's a track record here yeah
yeah
and so
so so rich bbc yeah not not just amy
so now now okay
but then she starts posting after she
gets out
thirst traps after she's killed yes and
so like she now one what that's one
theory
one
one one theory is that maybe it was
scheduled right you're a content creator
maybe i would think you know
you could take it off the schedule
with that amount of money that she's
probably making yeah on only time she's
going to take a break
right and this is a luxury apartment so
this is like they're in like a very nice
it's like 10k a month to live there so
so 8k bail is nothing she's out she's
partying and like
people are following her around
basically like when she's partying being
like what are you what are you doing
yeah because it's kind of a bad look
like your boyfriend
yes it is a bad boy it's so great isn't
it no no and on top of that on top of
that she didn't go to the funeral
i'm i mean i don't know if you were like
i mean she murdered him
yeah i think that's not going to be
probably would have got jumped if she
right yeah exactly right because if i
was yeah if i was the family member of
that guy or his friend she would get
jumped like no doubt about it i'm sorry
but a black family don't play about that
you ain't gonna just murder my
my family and turn up at the funeral
right right right saying her respects
right
pay my respects to my murder victory now
now now let's let's play devil's
advocate for her right
long there's been a long history of
domestic disputes courtney has called
the police seven times in the last month
on him
okay
yes yes like he definitely has he ever
called
for her
not the evidence so far no no so far
okay because men don't really report
domestic abuse you know that right they
don't really report no no um
so she has not actually been
formally charged or i guess she hasn't
been charged i don't i heard mixed
things about this the the last video i
watched said she i think she just was
but she was on like bail like it was 8k
so she can get out
i don't i should so they're yet to go to
trial then yes yes
um but now
another thing happens okay
florida is a stand your ground state do
you know what that means yeah um i
personally did not until i googled it
together i've heard of it before
um so
prosecutors must thoroughly disprove a
self-defense claim before filing legal
action
so she's saying it's self-defense so
prosecutors have to disprove that right
which is going to be difficult because
she has called police seven times in the
last month
now
it gets even more racy okay
because then they start going through
his tweets
and they find out this man
was tweeting about how he only dates
white girls and saying some pretty like
derogatory things about so she's saying
showing dates black guys he's saying he
only dates white house yeah let me let
me find out they sound like they sound
like a match
i was gonna say a match made in hell but
sure
so i mean they found each other one of
them died but i guess like so christian
but but so christian
so christian's old tweets
oh no it's not loading they were they
were pretty bad though like along the
lines of like like white girls boobs are
better than black girls boot like
bashing black women and said all lives
matter
i mean there's like
if if he likes white girls so be it do
you know what i mean but don't like like
white girls and then hate other people
do you know what i mean i've always said
to people if you like something like it
do you want me to like do it in the
positive not in the next yeah why you
gotta hate other people so
so no no so there's a lot of people
coming forward that like like the from
the black community that say well you
didn't you didn't like support us when
you were alive so why should we care
basically like a lot of there's a lot of
women like coming forward and saying
that okay
right
especially saying like oh your boobs are
[ __ ] and white goes
okay
so black girls disgrace themselves on tv
in another i'm tired of these black
girls in my government class
wow but how old are these tweets too
that's the other thing i feel like we
need context because he said government
class but ain't this a grown man yeah
but he said it two years ago he's in his
heart already so uh
that's very true that's who he is yes
yeah yeah i mean people can change
though he's talking about black women
disgracing themselves but he's with an
only fans model not that i'm shaming
only fans models because it sounds like
you are though
no i i'm pro-sex work no matter how you
put it however we know that society
views
women who do sex work as hang on your
pro sex work pro sex work so you think
sex work is cool
i i support women who do it i didn't say
it was cool i didn't say that i would do
it i didn't say other people should do
it i said that i support it you because
at the end people giving away their
vagina for money
um
she is just posting her coochie and
making money off of it
right she's selling the coochie that's
on her it's not my coochie
no i know that but you said you said
your pro sex work yes meaning i'm going
to always support somebody who is in
that industry as well at the end of the
day that's the way that they want to
make money okay so as my friend if i did
sex work you'd support it
yes if you feel like that that is
absolutely necessary for real he's not
done talking okay
if i feel like it's if you feel like
it's absolutely necessary and you have
no other out and it's against your
morals i would want to talk you out of
it if anything if it's fully against
your morals and maybe your family would
be against it but if you feel fully
comfortable with doing it of course i'm
going to support you but i'm going to
tell you to be very careful that's for
sure
interesting interesting
it is interesting mm-hmm i i don't think
i would support someone that didn't
sexually no i would tell them not to do
it but i mean i guess i i think your
point is like if you're gonna do it like
i can't stop you but that's exactly it
who the hell am i to tell somebody what
to do these people are my kids
what do i look like
what do i look like being their mom
you gotta pull the mic yeah well stated
is that um obviously you can't stop
anyone doing anything but i'm not gonna
encourage you doing it
if you feel like i didn't already
explain myself clearly that's your own
personal problem
if you want to do what you want to do
then you go ahead and do it at the end
of the day it doesn't matter what the
hell i say if you feel in your heart
that you want to do it you go and do it
regardless
what i say does not matter
but if you feel like you need somebody
at the end of the day that's going to
support you because nobody's there for
you i'm going to be a good friend to you
at the very least and be like listen bro
if you really feel like this is for you
i can't stop you
obviously your family couldn't stop you
why would i be able to stop you
it's your body if you're bodily
autonomous
there's a difference in that and saying
that you're pros yeah yeah exactly so
you know what i'm saying like that's a
statement like
pro means support does it not in this
case no no
stands for progressive yes
keep going keep digging deeper
uh progressive as in
the forward movement yeah so you're
you're forced to you're
movement of sex work i'm not anti
right because i allow other people to do
what they want right that is support i
think we are getting our terminology
she's mixed up yeah yeah it sounds like
you guys are getting your turn
and stuff like that i mean i can't stop
him but you know i'm pro-drugs yeah
exactly because i'm your friend i'm
gonna say this is bad for you bro you
got a family drugs can literally quite
literally kill you like soaking sex with
you yes unless you are careful enough it
is not so good but you can do the same
thing with drugs like like unless you
are carrying drugs yeah you know still
survive that's fine but the fact that
y'all want to
compare it to drugs is like a whole
different ball no it's just it's the
same it's the same i almost think sex
work is worse
because because you could do like you
could do drugs get sober no one would
ever know but you put [ __ ] on the
internet that's there forever
and whose business is that but their own
yeah all the people that see it on the
internet but that's my point that's
their life i can't do much about it at
the end of the day these people are just
my friends that much is true though
that's the reason why i would not
encourage my friend doing it saying
there's going to be long-term
consequences if you do this but don't
you think that they would have thought
that through several times already
before getting into it not necessarily
because they're in a
uh how can i put it heightened state
whereby they they're work they're
working emotionally and not logically
how many people do you know when sex
work
i don't surround myself okay the
positive enough how many people do you
know inspiration
okay there you go then i don't want to
hear it anyway let's continue
it's just a friendly conversation yeah
but i don't surround myself with it oh
okay well if it's not
should we take the gloves off now
okay the glove's been off
oh he hasn't even gotten started
like i don't surround myself with the
president doesn't mean does it mean that
i cannot have an opinion on the
president who the hell no i'm just
saying because the president is one
person right and so
are everywhere okay
you were just saying that if you don't
surround yourself with sex workers you
can't really have an opinion
yeah that too i agree
i agree
okay um so back to the case yes thank
you
what do you got what is your take on the
case you've heard all the evidence that
i know let me know if i missed anything
in the chat
but what do you guys think happened
i mean i read this story i'm gonna be
completely honest here i read it and i
had to read it again
because the first thing that came to
mind was you've killed someone
and you're out in public right so you've
been in hospital because you you know
you're suicidal
and then you're out at a bar with your
dad a couple days later right
so hang on a minute
in my brain you have stabbed someone to
death whether or not it'd be
manslaughter self-defense you've killed
someone and you're out in public
now if it roles were reversed and it was
him
do we think that would happen absolutely
no no no no no
and especially he's a black man too yeah
do you know what i mean so that would
have weighed on that would have helped
people out what this
black man is out in public after killing
this and i angelic white girl or
something i don't know how would i know
everybody would have painted it you know
what i mean
it's just not right for me and the fact
that she was then posting on only fans i
think two days after the incident
happened i mean
is that
maybe i don't know all of this maybe i
should
because i think anyone who does that is
normal
no like it's so disrespectful
and the fact like
i just if that was a dude or even a
black girl like i think that the
situation would be completely different
like i think they would be in jail yeah
100
i think the optics just look crazy about
it because both scenarios look plausible
it looks like there was some sort of
domestic thing between both of them
because they're just toxic for each
other it's a combination he's hitting
her he's hitting him she's reacted and
obviously eventually killed him but even
if you kill someone even with
self-defense
by your conscience if i've murdered
someone i've gotta literally be
withdrawn and just not not see the world
the fact that you're partying thinking
was that deliberate don't you have any
sort of remorse because her life's been
taken
maybe she she could have planned it
well and that's the that's the other
thing like
i was telling i was telling cheska
earlier when we were talking about this
like i think that men are abused more
than women
and i don't think it's necessarily
because like what type of abuse you
talking about like physically i think
women like hit men all the time men just
don't report it yeah i'm not like i've
been slapped in the face before yeah and
i think i didn't report it yeah yeah but
i think it's because it's out before i'd
lit up the whole place but you know like
what i don't i don't necessarily
actually because because if that happens
right and he reacts the way he's
supposed to react yeah
he already knows that it's going to be
exactly nice yeah once once the police
get called yeah he's going to be seen as
aggressive i will challenge you on this
one pearly in terms of like i don't
think
men get physically abused by women that
much i think it's more emotionally
yeah you see because think about it from
a perspective females are really good
with their words women yeah women okay
i'll say that women are really good
what's wrong with females
are good with their good with their
words something to do with the left side
of the brain so they could literally
tear a mouth limb for limb and because a
man can't verbally respond yeah we don't
that's the same way so what do we do the
only thing we know is
we use differences i think i don't
necessarily think like are you not
condoning domestic violence no i'm just
explaining that the dynamics of it
just to clarify i just think when you
take away the consequences of anything
like people will do it more and we see
women like the consequences are taken
away they can get away with it more than
men can
and and so
why because the justice system doesn't
favor men
like men get three times the like i
think i think it's either three or four
times the sentencing for the same crime
so is that because
um
women
are able to
is that because they're seen as more
delicate creatures
i think so yeah is that what you think
yeah probably but but also and they can
cry yeah also if you cry you just
automatically even from me yeah
ultimately believer because you think
yourself why we should cry if it's not
true and i think women know that and
that's what and i just
well i think there's like there's shitty
women and there's good women there's
shitty men and there's good men but i
think when you give like people like i
think even shitty men will think um i
don't want to go to jail
you know like you know like maybe maybe
i shouldn't hit her because like i want
to drop the soul yeah yeah but so so if
you give like shitty people the
opportunity to get away with stuff like
she killed him eight grand like that's
crazy that eight grand thing is crazy
correct me if i'm wrong florida is one
of the states whereby they've still got
the capital punishment system so if
she's effectively killed someone she
could be on death row
yeah but
it should be yeah but then again this is
not murder this is mostly most likely
manslaughter i don't think she
deliberately wanted to kill him i think
it was more of a case of a domestic
that's gone wrong
do we know but that's still not
remorseful is she regardless of how it
went usually when it comes to capital
punishment in whichever states that it
happens in they still go with
you're either going to get murdered or
you're getting life
but there's a distinction between
manslaughter and murder can i just say
on manslaughter i don't understand why
the walk movement haven't gravitated
towards that because it's manslaughtered
it should be said it's people it's
people's shoulder
like is that what it should be or
woman's slaughter no no no it puts men
in a bad way it's like non-binary
smaller
i don't know i mean i think you've
started
a debate for another day right yeah i'm
just saying that it's not manslaughter
anymore guys it's like person slaughter
um okay i'm gonna i'm gonna read super
chats really quick so um blue pill
unplugged my ex couldn't provoke me into
hitting her she repeatedly called the
cops anyway to build records slash
pattern to use in the divorce women know
the system oh i've heard of that
actually
um sex work donated i'm cool admit it
um mr rydo i wonder if she's had any
abortions the girl that
the only fans girl
um i don't think i
literally think i don't know i literally
done a show on abortion yesterday
do you believe in abortion
i'm i'm pro-life you're pro-life i am
begging us not to open up this can of
worms
[Music]
oh i'm done with the super chats okay
awesome
abortion's not good for folks okay
literally nobody asked anyway um
[Music]
um
be more careful folks
sorry anyway
um okay so
what do you guys think so do you guys
think there was
like she would have any case in like
like do you think she was being abused
in that relationship based on the
evidence based on evidence sounds like
they were both being abused i agree i
agree completely now there's also an
article that states that
well
again what what do you believe that he
was involved in human trafficking and
that she was being trafficked mm-hmm so
this is another thing that's that's a
home okay i didn't hear about this so
yeah go ahead was that another story
that came up yeah yeah i think i think
it was on the daily
mirror daily mirror yep that he was
trafficking her
but that she had to be pretty how long
were they together do you know i thought
it was a couple years i thought it was
like that's not human trafficking no i
don't i mean they
yeah
i mean i i can't comment too much
but that's that's what they were going
with as you know a defense for her
i think they're trying to they're trying
to paint a picture of him
yeah
and why doesn't her lawyer tell her to
put her phone away like
like he probably knows that she's gonna
get away with it regardless yeah for
being honest here they know that they
don't have to push as hard especially if
it's a white woman all it takes is some
crocodile tears for her to get away with
this and she's good to go put the grape
sign on there and before you know it
yeah you know
that's it
i'm sure i'm sure it sounds like in the
coming months we're going to hear
more from her
and she'll probably not like we can hear
from him yeah yeah
[Music]
and she'll probably spin a story of some
kind of i don't know there's gonna be a
netflix show on it yeah that's what it's
gonna be like he was so abusive and he
raped me he was a he was a narcissist
well that's the thing with these like
that's the thing with it's like we're
rewarding bad behavior with the media
because now like she's gonna be a
celebrity basically everyone's saying
that though don't as the audience want
that we want those trashed stories
because we eat it up because the media
won't promote it if there was an
audience for it i know you've got
awesome well they're just consuming this
crap well it's more like the justice
system should come in and we should be
able to hate them in prison
like
at the very least like you know ted
bundy was well known but we could hate
him in prison yeah he's a celebrity
yeah well it's the same thing with the
tinder swindler though he built him a
career delusion when it comes to ted
bundy and all of them because like how
many movies have we had on ted bundy
alone yo they're the amount of
sexualizing that they've done to this
man and romanticizing
it's like people forgot that he quite
literally murdered people yeah but it
doesn't kind of speak to the psychology
of
this world like people are abs like they
find murder quite
i mean
you know what i mean
that's because
people who run media made it that way
they could have made it more informative
and more disgusting i guess to repulse
people but instead when you look at like
the one with zac efron for example like
that movie where he played as ted bundy
it really romanticized the hell out of
that movie i watched it and i was like
he murdered people right like yeah just
wanted a reminder yeah but it's easy to
blend the media but then again if the
audience is not there to have it we love
to watch those stories sex and violence
yeah it sells i do have sex no i'm not
even gonna lie like that ted bundy
netflix here there's fire like i can't
even
i can't i can't in the series but i know
that the movie itself was like
i think it speaks to the primal
there's something in human beings that's
quite primal exactly you know what i
mean exactly and and when we see that
kind of stuff either sex or violence it
sparks something exactly look at the
subconscious yeah you look like you look
at history you look at when the
gladiators but they were killing each
other look how the auditoriums were well
fill up you look and those guys got
girls exactly not to mention what
happened in mark i think marvel arts
when they used to do the executions yeah
yeah people came ahead and watch it yeah
it's stuff like that people came to
watch lynch exactly there's something in
the human psyche i believe
no i agree but it's it's kind of like
it's like everyone it's like that even
getting in media you probably understand
the snout too a little bit better
because once you start creating content
you realize like how much the titles and
stuff you have to make it like
click-baity because you almost want to
outrage people so they'll like click it
you're like the more juicy the headline
or do you see the thumbnail because
people want to see the outrageous stuff
they do they just do
well i guess part of that is it makes
people feel better about themselves in
their own lives when they've got their
own things going on that
there's really bad stuff going out there
actually my life seems pretty
you know okay yeah and also it makes you
feel like a good person because you're
thinking well i'm not that bad
i might be a bit effed up but i'm not
that bad i didn't do that yeah yeah yeah
what do you guys think
i'm i'm just curious from the men do you
guys know anybody that's a guy that's
been so i know you said you've been
slapped yeah i've been snapped do you
know is it common would you say among
men like to have been hit by a girl
um probably more common than we think we
just don't report it because we're too
ashamed because we don't tell each other
exactly
that their wife or their girlfriend hit
them yeah they're not gonna say that
exactly and what about you guys like do
you feel like it's common among your
female friends to be like like i don't
personally know anybody oh wait actually
i do i know one person
but i know one girl and like more than
one guy like i know more than one guy
that's been like hit and i know probably
one girl so like in my personal life
like i know more guys than girls that
that's happened too what about you guys
i mean
with the people in my life it's pretty
even like i know quite a bit of women
and men who have both been abused in
their relationships and
both of them have equally opened up to
me about being abused
um it does hurt a little bit more though
i'm not gonna lie to hear about men
getting abused because then it's like
i don't know like it's kind of it's
weird to see
because that shows you that women have
no fear in them
when it comes to attacking a man yeah
like me like you know no matter what who
if someone were to like come at me first
i'm always going to defend myself i will
fight you like i am a man myself right
right but it does scare me to see that
women attack men when they're not
provoked to in the first place or
they're not being hit first
and i've seen it like quite a few times
and it even happened with my own parents
like my mom used to beat up on my dad
very early on in the relationship
and my dad never did anything about it
and mind you my dad is huge he's six
foot two buff like he could fight
he could defend himself but my mom is a
small five foot four stature woman so
can i say the reason why that might have
happened is because your dad knew the
implications of him hitting back
well my dad doesn't lay his hands on
women
period yeah no i hear that does
understand that there would have been a
problem if he did say something to
someone else in the family because
unfortunately my family was quick to
take my mother's side not knowing my mom
was the villain the whole time but do
you think your dad knew that if he did
retaliate physically that it would look
so bad on him yeah because my mom has
lied about my dad hitting her and i
obviously i was there
so i never saw him lay hands on her
and i know what type of person he is
obviously because i've been around him
24 7. i'm a daddy's girl but that
doesn't mean that i'm gonna defend him
if he was hitting my mom right you know
like i see i see [ __ ] for what it is
that's just a fact about me i appreciate
you sharing that because not a lot of
women would say that about their dads
yeah you know they will say the opposite
not should defend their mom saying oh my
oh my dad was yeah no you need to say
that that's really quite honest i'll be
honest my mom was trifling i have seen a
lot of trifling women in my life
unfortunately and it's disappointing
but
uh luckily a lot of the men in my life
at least that had gone through that like
they handled it really well like i would
say like for
guys that got attacked consistently and
like really were not the villain in the
story like they handled it really well
but don't you think like
it's easy see that's the thing like it's
easy for the woman to be the victim
do you know what i mean in these kind of
situations
because they're already naturally
smaller and they automatically assume
like you're a man you're this big and
you're this strong it shouldn't it
doesn't hurt does it like but then what
happens when women
understand that they can be seen as a
victim and they have an ego
and they have narcissistic traits or
whatever i think it turns out worse
do you know what i mean because if you
know that
it's that whole thing of
if you're a leader of a country and you
know you can't be touched you just might
be out of control because you know no
one can touch you yeah is that i mean i
mean how that works psychologically yeah
humans are not built to have power
naturally like the stanford prison
experiment proves that easily
i think humans are humans are built out
of power they're not
psychologically they're not don't argue
with me on this
okay so okay so so make me understand i
would agree with you
so for example
like balance
in the persian empire
the king could not do anything without
him getting i think approval from his
advisors because they realize that hang
on a minute if we give one man absolute
power he can absolutely abuse that we
don't even have to go that's why we can
just look at america now and how
the president like of the us they have
to go through several checks and
approval through several steps before
they can pass anything that they want to
do then how the hell did biden become a
president then
what that doesn't have to do with me
anyway
seriously though like these rules have
to be set in place because humans
naturally especially the average human
cannot handle power even if it's the
tiniest bit of it like so do you guys
think that if a man or a woman hits a
man he should be able to hit back
because
i i feel like
if a girl is to the point like she
brings out a knife i feel like knock her
out
i just like genuinely like i'm sorry if
you bring a knife to this fight knock
her knock that equal
but obviously there are circumstances
whereby if someone like you mentioned if
someone has a knife do you hit that
person i think ideally if i was in that
circumstance you tried to wrestle her
i'm pinned that down
then you might you might end up like
dude possibly
right over here
[Music]
that was to happen the narrative would
say
big black guy kills woman okay no
context whatsoever right yeah okay so
they're gonna jump to that immediately
self-defense 100 if you're defending
yourself because someone's coming at you
of course you're going to defend
yourself like i don't want to die no one
wants to die yeah defend yourself yeah
but i don't condone violence full stop
so if someone's hitting someone just
walk away just leave that situation get
out of there but it's easier that's said
than done isn't it because when you're
an abusive relationship it's not just
about the physical abuse it's about the
mental torture that you are put through
all the time continuously and i think in
some ways and i'm not condoning this at
all why sometimes people lash out and
are physically violent is because
mentally and emotionally spiritually
they've been abused so much
that literally their soul is is crushed
they're a shell of a person now as i
said i'm not condoning it but this is
it's the human psyche
you said should a man be able to hit
back mm-hmm yes
i i'm with you
i mean it's that simple like i will say
i don't i think there's levels right so
if like i feel like girls like play hits
sometimes you don't even know yeah
but like i feel like if she's
say it pal say it yeah
i feel like if she brings a knife to the
fight you should hit her i but make sure
you record that stuff so she's not
saying that she's like she's going to
wake up with a black eye
but i think if if a woman thinks that
she can physically
um
abuse a man
then she's obviously a little bit
delusional oh yeah because physically
men are stronger than women
right but
that but then there's an age-old thing
of
if you want to control somebody no
matter how big and strong they are you
just control their mind the question is
to see sarah is this though if a woman
is beating up the man
has the man allowed it to happen because
has he not set boundaries himself he's
psychologically beaten down before she
can actually hit him so even if you're a
strong man that sets boundaries do you
think no if you set boundaries in from
the beginning if you know how to set
boundaries then you know how to leave at
the end of the day but somebody who
claims that they set boundaries but
still stick with that bs is definitely
not strong on their boundaries and
definitely doesn't know how to stand for
themselves so could the beast not be
resentment because the woman's thinking
this guy gets me it lets me get away
with stuff so i'm just going to test the
boundaries because i want drugs that's
exactly how it goes that's exactly how
abuse works it just keeps leveling up as
time goes along they like to see how
much control they can have over you
until it comes to a point where they
have full and total control over you and
you have nothing you can't do anything
about it
like your family probably try to talk
you out of the relationship you're
friends you probably had therapy and
you're still there like why do you why
do you think people stay in toxic
relationships they they can't mentally
leave
manipulation yeah manipulation and it
stems from narcissism doesn't it they're
broken down to the point where they
physically can't leave because mentally
they're elsewhere they've gone
it's it yeah
do you think that
there's any responsibility on the person
being abused for not leaving when they
do have the choice assuming that person
isn't threatening them if they like they
have the right to leave i mean yeah but
it's like stockholm syndrome isn't it
yeah i mean like yeah you can
once you build up as like i've always
said the mind is stronger than a body
anyway do you know what i mean and and
to control somebody's mind
no matter how big they are
you have control over that person
doesn't matter how much muscles they've
got or how tall they are if you control
their mind you will be the one
in control exactly so for example we
always think who is what is the
strongest animal in the king in the
animal kingdom
it's probably the elephant elephant but
why is the lion the king of the jungle
attitude it's actually the ant
but anyway um
wait why
they can hold over 100 times their
weight
physically
yeah but they're not going to beat a
lion
no obviously not but hypothetically
they're technically one of the strongest
oh you mean like the strongest okay okay
but what i was gonna say before um damn
y'all messed me up cause y'all kept
going and going
i was trying to jump in but then i got
scared to jump in the ring i think we
were either talking about hitting back
or we were talking about um why like
people stay oh you don't have any
accountability
the issue with that is that
90 of the reason we are the way we are
today is because of our childhood
if you come from a home where you are
used to abuse
whether it be verbal physical mental
whatever it may be
you're going to be susceptible to it
later on in your
future intimate relationships even in
your friendships do you feel like
there's a certain age that you can't
blame your childhood anymore
no because i think
i don't think what happens as a child
obviously
always will always to some degree always
stick with us yeah that we choose
whether we're gonna let that control us
for the rest of our lives or not but
yeah for example if you were abused as a
child right that's always going to be it
depends if it's if it's living in your
conscious or subconscious exactly
because a lot of the time our conscious
behaviors are uh because of our
subconscious right
but if you are consciously saying oh i'm
going to do this because of my childhood
and yeah you you're typically
consciously choosing yeah you're going
to be an [ __ ]
because you want to make excuses
it's your problem okay at that point but
genuinely it really depends on when you
decide to unpack the trauma right cause
like you know when it comes to being
from a minority family you know like
i promise you all my aunts and uncles
have been abused at some point by my
grandmother or grandfather you know
whoever it may be it's very common
especially in the caribbean
um but my dad only really started
unpacking the problems behind that
within the last 10 years i would say my
mom hasn't done that at all you know
and i if she were to sit down with me
today and be like i realized what i went
through in my childhood was messed up
and this is why i am the way i am today
i would think that she has every right
to say that and i would think that she
has every right to blame her childhood
because she only just realized no i i
understand that i just think like
like i understand saying okay this is
the cause of that behavior and that's
good to know but i just think over a
certain age you can't make the excuse of
your childhood anymore yeah no like you
like like that is the problem then it's
up to you i feel like you know that i
feel like there's that i feel like
there's an archetype of a guy that just
i think okay so if you know you're like
this because of your childhood
if you're aware and you use it as an
excuse that's when it becomes a problem
right okay because i have been in
relationships where people will be like
i got trust issues like
my mom beat me when i was seven like
okay so you're aware of that why not
unpack that well i'm like what did i
maturity comes into the place whereby
you acknowledge you have this side of
you because of past trauma which you
can't control right you have a
responsibility to say okay this is how i
feel i'm not gonna put myself in a
situation like a relationship whereby
these traumas that haven't been dealt
with could surface up and damage
sabotage their relationship
i guess you just shouldn't be in a
relationship if you haven't dealt with
your own demons in the first place i
mean everyone's got demons but it's
whether or not they resurface constantly
and it comes back to traumas again from
childhood are you a narcissist have you
built up this wall are you protected but
don't we all have demons usually that's
what we do that's when people get into
relationships the most when they're like
most psychologically [ __ ] up because
they can't find love anywhere else and
the mistake is the mistake is that my
partner is going to be my cure
and that's what messes people up
have you noticed that the most
narcissistic people jump from
relationship to relationship to relation
is that just me or do you know
that's a common thing so here's the
thing with me right so i was in a
relationship from when i was 18 to 25
like seven years six and a half seven
years right
and then
i was single i was single for like
six months and then i got into another
relationship and i was in that for like
two and a half
then i was single again for like maybe a
year and a half and then i got in my
next relationship i was in that for 10
years okay and
people say oh you're 40. like shouldn't
you have settled down by now and i'm
like you know what i was in a 10-year
relationship right took it out of me and
now i'm like you know what you need to
chill because that jumping from
relationship to relationship
kind of made me realize that
i had a i had an epiphany one day and i
was like i've spent like over half of my
life like half of my life in
relationships like who the hell are you
bro do you know what i mean and i think
it's not until you kind of like
have that realization that you can be
okay with yourself
do you know what i mean
until and and that will stop you jumping
from relationship to relationships
dependency is no laughing matter yeah no
no it's so true so should we always say
obviously if you're in the plane why
does this as you would say if the
monster must come you put your own first
before you can put it to another person
so i think that's a great analogy in
terms of relationship if i'm not healed
how the heck can i help anybody else
yeah yeah
okay i'm gonna read a super chat real
quick um eat godly thank you for the
super chat if she hits me i spank her
and yes i've done it
okay
i think he's talking about another type
of spanx um
thank you kinky thank you you know what
i'll i'll say whatever you want give me
money
okay also guys all super chats are going
to that's sex work what do you mean i'll
say whatever you want and as long as you
give me money
[Music]
when you put it like that
okay guys no but for real all super
chats are going towards a second camera
like how nice would it be you guys when
i'm talking right now you could see me
head on wouldn't that be nice so i don't
get any of that money no you don't get
any of this yeah i don't get any of that
no
i need to
get the equipment up
anyways guys so it would be a camera
here a camera here and you guys could
just really really see us
so send money send super chats okay
so um you had a story you wanted to tell
didn't you oh god this is a little off
topic but i think it'd be interesting
because it kind of plays into double
standards so yeah i mean i could share
that story but i'll keep it super vague
okay i'll keep it super vague and i
guess i'll talk about double standards
as it is i and i'm also going to come
back to your thing about people jumping
from relationship to relationship i
guess it depends on what you constitute
a relationship are we talking about like
a long term like i'm committed to you
you're committed to me because i think
in today's society especially with
social media and instagram
you know it's great but oh my goodness
isn't it the cause of so much infidelity
people
control themselves
into a candy store and saying look at
all the sweeties honey but don't you
touch is that kid gonna touch hell yeah
that kid's gonna so would you delete
your instagram for a guy
uh yeah if i'm really wrong about him
and he was really unhappy yeah yeah it's
not life
you would delete all your socials for
your guy yeah it's not my life
what about you what about you jessica if
you had a guy
no no
the hell do i look like doing anything
for a man i'm sorry but at the end of
the day
anyway pause
um
it's my life it's my social media if he
feels threatened by my social media
that's something that he has to unpack
himself no i'm not talking about i'm
talking about the statement that you
made what do i look like doing anything
for a man are you telling me that you
won't do anything for a man i'm it's a
joke bro breathe
no i'm just asking the question yes i
would do something for a man but it
really depends on how much i care about
him and
how long we've you know
cultivated a true relationship with each
other in a true connection
but regardless
social media like it's not that serious
if something as small as social media
holds weight to you in a relationship
grow the [ __ ] up
like genuinely grow the [ __ ] up if
you're going to sit there and be like
delete your instagram i can't handle
this unless i'm out here
in a different way
unless i'm cheating and flirting because
i was not done talking
anyway
if you're going if i could understand i
could understand
if i'm on there flirting and messing
around and cheating blatantly
absolutely you have every right to feel
that way but if i'm not doing anything
on my goddamn social media except for
posting a picture of me in front of a
bookstore or something
relaxing what if you're posting like
sexy pictures that men want to comment
on and stuff
what the hell does that have to do with
me i'll block the guys
yeah but you don't think it's a little
bit you don't think it's a little bit
like attention seeking like because i
feel like you shouldn't post those traps
in a relationship do you agree or
disagree i don't know what the hell it's
like to post the thirst trapped in a
relationship oh well i mean i use that
what i use what is that cause she's
never been in one in a relationship yeah
i've been in quite a few reasons she
just got out of a relationship i just
got out of one no i'm just asking i'm
just asking um
but i've been in a relationship at least
where my partner kept on
getting booty hurt because of my
instagram because i was a micro
influencer at the time
and i don't i don't know what exactly
hurt him about it to this day
but there was like one bikini picture on
there and it wasn't like super raunchy
and sexy like it was just me by the pool
side mm-hmm
in a bikini like i feel like i should be
able to do that quickly period if i'm in
lingerie now that's a different story
yeah but you have to remember men are
territorial
naturally we are okay well we're not
animals so
you're not you're not gonna piss on me
to prove that you're i'm yours okay but
we are
for example what does she look like
doing anything for a man so what if he
was posting like like
shirtless selfies like you wouldn't
that's totally up to him he's not gonna
i'm not going to be insecure over that i
know that my man is fine i just don't i
know that he's gonna get attention off
of it but it's up to me to trust him to
not entertain the [ __ ] in his dms
well i just think that's like a bad sign
like if i was in a relationship and the
guy was posting like shirtless selfies
and all this attention-seeking photos
i'd be like um i feel like i'm getting
cheated on that that's a matter of
boundaries that you would set in your
own relationship right relationships it
hasn't been a problem aside from one
time no no that's fine and so you could
say like you wouldn't accept that
you don't have to do a relationship you
know
i do not it seems like you would
because i have an aggressive nature to
me that i think scares you a little bit
no i'm however which is good i'm just
analyzing it
um no i do not dominate the relationship
i make sure it's equal at all costs i
make sure that both of us always have an
opportunity to speak
say what's on our minds and set the
boundaries that are necessary and we
make compromises as necessary but i
definitely do not dominate and i make
sure my partner does not dominate either
because at the end of the day we are our
own individuals we can do what we please
as long as we're not upsetting each
other and doing things to intentionally
hurt each other
so you agree that you have an aggressive
nature
yeah
absolutely because
i'm very opinionated do you think that's
like dominating in a relationship no
because as aggressive as you yes he was
but that's exactly what made it fun
between us and the times that i have
dated men yeah because we can both
handle each other just fine
most of the time when our relationships
end the xu called didn't sound a great
was he really on the same level as you
because he really actually he didn't he
didn't sound like it no see but he had
grown a lot since then i don't know him
and i dated okay well i don't care what
you believe
so
what's the hostility when um i just like
it i like getting juicy that's all yeah
when him and i dated we were in high
school right so that was a totally
different cesca that we're dealing with
right and a totally different hymn that
we're dealing with you know back then
you know he was a serial cheater for
sure like he was walling out all the
time and i think i think he would have
i'm gonna be honest when he was on the
phone with you i think he would have
cheated again oh he absolutely would
have so
thank god huh did you no it was it was
she was on the show and it was like call
your ex and ask them on a date or
something and it was like he was like
kind of feeling the water
but he didn't he was but he didn't think
he did he knew he he knew you weren't
serious
because remember the last time on your
show yeah and i said um there are women
that say oh yeah guys cheat
and i said well women kind of cheat at
the same kind of rate that commented
right and i said does anyone here cheat
nope i haven't cheated no i haven't so
it's like oh okay so women never really
admit are you saying are you saying that
everyone on the panel was lying listen
listen i can't i don't have a lie
detector test up but i'm just saying
it's very interesting that women
call out men's cheating and not their
own do you know what i mean there is a
famous saying that the heart is
deceitful above all things and
desperately wicked what's that bible
verse yes it talks about how
yeah so
i think it's about sorry i think it's
about setting boundaries though isn't it
it's what you're both comfortable with
from the beginning because i think this
is where things can get complicated and
people can right right and it's again
double standards so say for example you
you were liking something of someone and
your partner didn't like it but then
they were doing the same and they asked
you not to do it
and then but they continued on doing it
well that's double standards
i believe i honestly believe you should
never tell someone what to do you should
let a person make their own choice if
you tell someone look it's kind of made
me a bit unhappy
i'm not i'm not too fond of that but if
i understand in context whilst you're
doing it and they say well this is this
that's how that's my friend or whatever
then fine but if they're then
deliberately continuously doing
something that you've said you know it
makes you feel a bit uncomfortable then
it's acting out a malice isn't it it's
disrespectful yeah do you know what i
think
there was a statement that i had read
i'm going to butcher it a little bit but
it was like you can tell someone how to
love you but it's up to them to decide
how to love you at the end of the day
yeah so based on their actions if they
truly love you they're going to do what
is necessary for you yeah at the end of
the day so
i guess it's knowing each partner's love
language exactly sometimes that's the
main thing i think what happens in
relationship when relationships go sour
is that because my love language could
be words of affirmation but if i project
that's my partner's love language that's
where things can go wrong yeah and all
of a sudden i'm saying but i'm giving
you gifts because people have a tendency
to love others in their own love
language that's the problem women can
change their minds very easily what
would you say so can men
take women's love languages
we're setting stone marks yeah men are
more set in stone than women
like so many girls on instagram i'm not
saying everyone but i'm saying some
people do i mean you're saying simple
but i don't think so because if it was
that simple would there'd be so much
choice on instagram
it's a small percentage of men that can
even do that
right
like um it's a very small percentage of
men that are even like sleeping with
anybody like that's the reason girls
hate men is because we're sleeping with
the same ones
no i'm like dead like because it's what
do they say if you ask eighty percent of
women what they like look for in a guy
they list twenty percent of men
of men and then the other the bottom
twenty percent of women like the eighty
percent of men are fighting over
basically
i i think the majority of men don't even
get like men's life generally average
men is a very lonely existence
whereas women women don't get okay so an
average an average woman
can walk out of a house looking regular
in a traxxy or like with a bonnet on or
whatever and still get attention from it
[Applause]
[Music]
and the average man walking out his
house does not get any attention his
dm's are dry yeah he doesn't get any
attention sounds like a rough life
i'll be easy out there though i'm just
saying that like the average guy doesn't
get the same thing that an average woman
would get that's what andrew tate says
that like women don't know real
loneliness because there's always
someone that'll date a girl like even
like the girls on 500 pound life have
like boyfriends but
but
you get 500 pounds 300 whatever it is
no no they do they still but like like
that's what i'm saying what they call
feeders you guys just feed them yeah
yeah but i'm saying like like men don't
have that there's guys that oh my gosh
there's guys in my like that dm me and
like tell me really
sad existence stories like this one guy
no like this one is like he'll like dm
me and be like i'm addicted to hookers
because i like i've never touched i've
never had a girl express interest in me
at all ever
communicate that's what i said because
the average guy doesn't know what
quote-unquote game is yeah well that's
why he doesn't know what that's what i
told him i was like respectfully it has
to be your personality because i was
like you can't do this no no because he
sent me pictures and he like he's like
black pill and he's like oh it's over
for me and he's like am i like that ugly
and i was like you're kind of average
looking to be honest like it's gotta
yeah it's gotta
i think he had a degradation kink at
that point you can't change your
personality man i know so i think he's
morale he's just down down the bottom
sorry men's is down astronauts
that is one of the reasons why you and i
experience when we speak the way we
speak the comment section
a lot of angry men
like those are the men those guys that
i'm not i listen i'm about advocating
for men but a lot of guys who are quite
average who don't get female attention
get quite angry at that fact do you know
what i mean and they start to take their
anger and frustration out they become
the female versions of the feminists
that they criticize exactly and this is
too much it's like bro you need to calm
down maybe work on yourself try and get
yourself a personality try and go to the
gym or whatever you know i mean you
can't get yourself a personality
on amazon 20 off and one i think i think
true masculinity is like rare and i
think a lot of a lot of guys could bat
out of their league to be honest if they
were more masculine
one hundred percent because women are
attracted to me remember yeah yeah yeah
you don't you're not right because i
think we had this conversation like a
different show was that you it might
have been someone else like you don't
do you like care if a guy's masculine or
not no you don't care that's because
you're the aggressive one right no
[Music]
already anyway but you also did you also
date like because girls my sexuality is
very fluid yeah and so is my identity so
i don't necessarily have a problem with
my partner expressing themselves on the
more feminine or masculine spectrum as
long as they're comfortable i am more so
somebody who dates someone for their
soul i don't really care i feel that yes
okay okay um it doesn't necessarily take
appearance for me to feel some type of
way about you you know i feel like if
the connection is there i'm genuinely
gonna like you yeah so what's the what's
the phrase when someone is in love with
someone because of the intellectual
capacity there's a word
yeah i i feel like that [ __ ] that's what
i am i feel like sapiosexual should just
be like like everyone dates for some on
some level
personality yeah
some people like to date dumb though
like
it's just trophy isn't it about having
that trophy person yeah i mean i'm not
gonna lie they like to feel better
knowing that they're the smarter person
in the relationship they want someone
they can put on their arm like this is
my partner look everyone don't speak
don't speak
or just say hi yeah just say hi
not even that but i don't know anyone
like that like i can't think of a single
person that i know in my personal life
that personality doesn't matter like of
course looks it starts with looks
there's so many like do you know so many
really
in my personal life in my dating
experience and it comes down to love
bombing doesn't it like how i attract a
male okay and at first i think okay he's
going to attract
a man an attractive attractive man and
he you know he
he he looks great and then you get to
know his personality and you're like
okay maybe not so much
but then they they lump on you they get
you in this thing where their loved one
was like oh baby i love you so much your
baby girl oh yeah you're there for me i
want to marry you want to marry you i'm
like you got to be crazy you don't even
know me that well
you want to marry me i've literally
spoken to you for two i think guys just
like say that
[Music]
they believe that it's going to entice
women to come in like oh you're my now
baby girl oh i love you so much baby
girl oh yeah the problem is that we call
that
something over here
absolutely we call that simping over
here the problem is that it does catch
some girl's attention because i actually
lost a friend last year over this
um
because me and all my friends have been
telling her for like months straight
like this guy does not care about you he
just love bombed you then he disappears
for a few weeks not giving you as much
attention yes
like he'll like text her maybe once or
twice a day or like disappear for a
couple days like it just it was back and
forth now they're apparently together
but like
they had done it for a year like it was
a year straight that they had been
dealing with this bs and i'm like
how did you stick around this long with
this lack of consistency like this guy
just love bombed you one time but
literally the first time that they met
he said i'm gonna give you my last name
now if a guy said that to me i'd be like
i need you to step back 10 17 steps
that's not it's not something it's a
formula
the thing is it's not simply it's a form
of manipulation it's a way to drag
someone into a relationship
sex though with the girl huh did the
girl just did the guy just want to have
sex with a girl that's what it seems
like at first but i guess not after a
while they ended up getting into a
relationship who am i to judge right but
except
they have other things going on so i was
thinking a basketball player last year
and i thought he was amazing like you
know we have this weird who
[Music]
and at the time i just come out this
really like awful relationship he was a
he was a love bomber as well and that
they all come back right they all come
back and it's like nobody
see you later han you think you're not
gonna come back i can guarantee two
months time you'll be back no no no yeah
but anyways taking this basketball
player everything seemed really really
great right he was living in france he
flew me over to france and i got there
and this is a true [ __ ] story and i'm
gonna swear because show me his
instagram right now oh god and he
doesn't want me he presents me with a
rose in a box and i was like that's
that's cute okay that's cute you know we
spent the whole weekend doing it was the
first weekend we met we stayed in studio
flat the whole weekend watching squid
games
[ __ ] not squid games okay then he
decided the next day he was going to
take this rose back to the supermarket
because you deserve better baby you
deserve the world he disappeared he
couldn't speak french i'm in there in
the supermarket speaking of french women
he wants to return this rose she's like
are you [ __ ] me i'm like no i'm
[ __ ] not [ __ ] you you wanted to
turn this rose why one just get another
one sounds like broke [ __ ] tendencies
like in in a box right so then he he he
said i'll come find you so i thought oh
maybe he's like planning this like
a surprise 45 minutes later and i'm
stood by some dead lilies he was like i
was going to get you these lilies like
that you know this is amazing i'm like
dude what is this like why did you you
bought me a gift and then you took it
back like i don't need anything i'm not
expecting anything so his love language
was
is it gifts like yeah it's just games
right so quite clearly because you know
that he thinks oh she doesn't either
yeah he flew me yeah he flew me out but
that okay he flew me out i was quite
happy to pay right he flew me out he
didn't pay for luggage or anything like
that i paid for luggage he pretended
like the luggage thing wasn't an issue
which isn't a problem i don't mind
paying my way you do not you do
understand for guy flies you're always
expecting sex right
uh we had sex once
over one weekend the first time we met
we were watching squid games is what
means we were watching squid games and
you know what i found out that he had a
girlfriend all along oh oh my gosh
that's like
show me his instagram
afterwards
let's not give him any air time though
no no oh my god basketball players as i
always say basketball
they ruin lives they're always like
do you know what when i left though and
i came back to london he then called me
up and decided that he didn't want a
relationship with me but that we should
carry on getting to know each other
because you know i said on what planet
do you live like i've just moved back to
london you live in france i'm i'm okay
thank you there are plenty of guys in
london that i could date who actually i
didn't know i had a girlfriend oh i
found out we find out we always find
um okay one look at the following
what it's over 2k he's a [ __ ] look at
who's he following and then who liked
his pictures
go through the picture
this was this was crazy he cried for 15
minutes on the phone begging me to stay
with him
guys don't do that
you know what i only found out a couple
months later and i felt
i was in two minds i was like do i
message her that's not your business
don't do that that's not your business
i will my business
when it comes to women if you truly want
to stick by women and help them out out
of this shitty situation you've got to
call it out
he decided to involve you in the
relationship when he decided to [ __ ]
with you
guys unless unless a guy has a friend
who he finds out that his girl is
cheating that's the only time generally
as men that we go out and go to our
friends say listen bro you know what
this
i've done it to girls i don't even know
like i wasn't even involved
like like i've i've seen i've seen a guy
because i've seen her guys
because the thing is you don't know the
aspects of it already look at it i've
seen it
would have said so yeah
right they would be like hey just want
to let you know if he's allowed to do
that you don't know
okay so what if he is then it's fine if
he is he would let you know because he
knows that you have access no no no no
no no no no the one the one
i think there can be a compromise in the
same way where you could threaten to say
you sort this relationship out speak to
your partner oh i'm gonna do it i think
that could you could give
yeah i have a story about this in
college my friend
this was my friend though actually so
this is probably one of the craziest
things i've ever done i'm i'm gonna own
it so
i'm gonna say it on camera so this my
friends have a little bit of crazy my my
friend was dating this guy went to a
different school
and this guy i i think i've told you
this story before i knew he was cheating
on her because he cheated on the last
girl all the time and i told her i was
like look
you can date him if you want i wouldn't
he was kind of a [ __ ] like he always
slid into my dms when he had like this
other no because he used to but i would
i would never like entertain it because
i was like i wasn't special he entered
it was like a copy yeah he was just
doing any go
yeah yeah
yeah yeah but anyway so he leaves our
school and he goes to a different school
right and so i don't know why like her
friend was like determined to catch this
man cheating and i was just like bored
this day i'm gonna be honest i had
nothing to do i was like oh this sounds
fun
volleyball end you know how it is when
volleyball ends and you just got a lot
of free time i was like i got you know
it was a drought a little bit
so she comes over and we're like she's
like i'm i'm tired of kaylin like like
he was being crazy towards her just
named him i don't care did you do that
well they broke up now sorry caleb
anyways anyways so what we decided we
were like okay he goes to a small school
let's look at the girls on the rosters
at the other school that look like her
so she kind of she kind of looked like
cheska a little bit like to be honest
like
no no no no like she kind of like why
did she have the same aggression as
[Laughter]
no jessica but anyway she looked like
jessica so i was like let me find the
girls because it was like a small like
like white school so like obviously
there's only going to be a couple black
girls yeah so we would just like dm the
black girls and be like yo do you know
kaelin like as he has he dm'd you and
like literally within like
i probably did this for 20 minutes it
didn't even take up an afternoon i was
kind of irritated so literally you went
to see all the black girls and we're
like yeah you know this guy do you know
this guy yeah yeah because girls will do
that like they'll d i mean like don't
they'll like we'll dm each other
sorry go on well i mean at that point i
had a lot of time
you don't even understand like
i'd like to complete tasks yeah and so
then i do not condone any of this i get
i get that i don't care
no i know i'm just saying i'm gonna i
don't know i'm saying this for the guy
and i do it again like
so actually no this one i wouldn't have
because i get the evidence i'm like look
at kyle
here here you i got to stop saying
people
whatever whatever just make up some
names so so yeah that was a fake name um
now sorry man there's so many cows in
this world please look at it like it so
i i get i get that i get the evidence
but then this this girl ends up like
going back to him and it's awkward for
me
cause then now the guy and all of his
friends at the school i'm the demon
of people's business because you don't
know their relationship and now i owned
it i was like you haven't
cheated on right and you're thinking oh
i'm gonna tell her yeah yeah the girl
he's and she goes back to him what was
the point well it doesn't matter you're
giving someone the opportunity to walk
around because you don't know you know
how i'm embarrassing but the thing is
you could like pearl said she ended up
looking like the demon she ended up
looking at the bad boy no it depends why
does it matter what we look like to
people yeah we don't stop getting
involved
and i do it again we know our intentions
whenever we do this whether it be some
people wanting to be trifling and we
just wanted to end in a relationship
stop it stop it for me i was bored
i'm going to tell you a little story in
fact it's quite a big story i kind of
dated a tinder swinner in the first
lockdown and this story is going to
it's going to send your mind a little
bit wild
did he ask him for 80 000 because his
enemies uh
close close very very close so this guy
i matched on tinder with i think like
2018 and he'd been kind of you know
messaging me for a while and to be
honest i looked at his instagram and i
thought this guy's fake he is too
beautiful to be real there's no way this
man is real that's when you got a
reverse image search
he is not real right anyway he he
started messaging me again and we got
chatting and it was literally the
beginning of like 2020 end of 2019 so i
agreed to meet him and we went on a date
and i was like oh my god he's actually
real but he'd been a little bit funny in
messages like a little bit arrogant and
i was like yeah i'm not digging your
vibe you may be pretty but your brain is
not that great so why did you go and see
him because i thought i'd give him a
chance because he really was pursuing me
this has been going on for two years so
i thought okay give this guy a go so he
went for a drink and he told me that his
mom had a charity in africa and
everything like this and you know that
really you know when someone does
something for the community i thought
okay this guy's pretty good
anyway
it all happened very fast lockdown
happened and um we ended up moving in
together which was the the biggest
mistake ever
wait you moved after how long okay i'm
not gonna lie like four weeks he decided
to like move
okay all right
i've been there move on okay
so anyway anyway this this kind of
happened you got what you deserve
yeah you got what you
it happened because we were both in a
financial situation where i was going to
have to go back to jersey and he was
going to have to go back to wherever he
lived i don't even know this man i don't
even know if he's real like his name is
really his name
so we ended up together because of the
situation not because we're like oh yeah
we love each other so much let's live
together because of the situation we
knew we liked each other we were
sexually attracted to each other and we
knew we got on can i just say you don't
move in
with anyone yeah if there's not that
element of what you just said no i get
that but it was a scary time wasn't it
at the beginning of lockdown nobody knew
what was going on like financially like
emotionally and i was living on my own
he was living at a hotel so we ended up
together okay now during the course of
this relationship a lot of weird things
started going on he started telling me
about this friend of his marie who lived
in dubai she was an air hostess and you
know she she was really sweet and it was
so great babe yeah she's got in contact
with me i'm gonna go and see her it's
amazing we're childhood friends from
paris now i can keep up with these
stories okay because he was born in
brazil then he was born in cameroon then
he was born in paris and i was like i
don't know bro like where are
you're living with this guy
and his story changes from cameroon to
brazil or brazil to cameroon yeah it
goes very complicated yeah but what what
what what is your reaction at least okay
so he started going off on we gotta
break this
down story is a little bit different
literally
i was so confused so confused so he kept
moaning at me that i wasn't commenting
on his photos on instagram i was like
why do i need to comment babe like i'm
right here with you would you not i'd
rather give you affection here he's like
no it's my life you need to comment on
my all my pictures all the time
no no no listen so i knew something was
going on so i commented once on a photo
right and then and then it exploded
my dms with girls
a girl first of all messaged me and
apparently he was in a relationship with
her and had been for six months an
online relationship she got so mad she
set up five fake instagram accounts she
released all his naked photos and videos
told these women to get in contact with
me
message the 300 and whatever woman he
was following told them to message me
and my inbox was flooded with messages
like oh my god he's been like so
why did he want you to comment i have no
idea was he trying to get rid of you
loki like he was he was trying to get us
to move to france in this fake house
that apparently his dad had that didn't
exist
can i just say
you got given multiple red flags
literally you got given multiple red
flags i mean yeah each red flag you
acted like an ostrich and you buried
your head in the sand right and so
there are too many women out there yeah
that's it right no you just have to take
a i'd take accountability i'm just
saying
when a guy says to you he was born in
cameroon but then all of a sudden he was
born in brazil yeah he's changing
you're going to be like
i had some wine at the time i didn't
know what was wrong
did i dream it like not the other
problem is that you also could have been
in fear because of the situation you
were in you said it yourself that yeah
was it hot how hot was he
feeling oh i'm gonna show you how let me
let me see
pull up his ig on the screen now watch
this now watch this now watch this right
here the fact that she was like
how hot he is yeah
still shows me he still shows me that
you still have a little bit of a twinkle
for me no no no no i promise you you
swear down
so he just to put things in perspective
what he did was he would set his hinge
and tinder to different jurisdictions in
the world so every month when his
benefit ran out because he was claiming
benefit in loads of different
jurisdictions
he had a child as well who couldn't
remember that's right so he'd meet women
in different jurisdictions and then find
his next place to live
oh my god and then he told all these
women that he lost like ten thousand
fifteen thousand same sub story my flat
um my roommate my friend his his house
in denmark and i lost my laptop all my
designer clothes my rolex my money and
he told the same story to these three
hundred people
at least he didn't get cash out of you
women do this guys all the time
the only reason why the tinder swindler
was a story is because guys don't
generally do this type of stuff they
don't generally swindle women out of
their money women are swindling men out
of their money because they don't have
women aren't dumb enough yeah that's
true
most of the time
no i think i think women
we definitely are dumb enough come on
come on
men men are just more like they have
more we speaking french because i don't
know who we is he's not going to be me
wait let me see let me see
i was like he has to be like
crazy good looking to get away with this
there's no way
he's actually homeless this guy but you
look at his i understand
when we were living together i had to
take photos of him outside houses and he
was pretending that honestly i can't i
can't
but i i came this is proof folks that
instagram really does not show you [ __ ]
right instagram really does not show you
[ __ ] like
yeah man's look like you live in the
time of his life and oh no he's not
homeless
yeah so the thing is right
um women are attracted to attracted to
shiny things uh-huh okay
and what you got shown there's a shiny
thing
very shiny
diamonds
okay and and the thing is men that
understand that women get attracted to
shiny things can exploit that just like
women that understand men get attracted
to women
right or their ass or their boobs or
their whatever can attract a guy like
that yeah but i'll be completely honest
i found him super boring right i'll be
completely honestly attractive people
are super boring i'm not boring he would
he would have about me because he was
like i can hear you on the phones your
guy makes you laughing you're gonna
leave me you get like really you know
worked up about it but i would not have
been with him had it not been for the
pandemic there's no chance in how i
would have continued dating him it was
just how long were you living with him
for three months about three months yeah
three months you're with this guy yeah
the same every day under the same day
yeah
yeah i know
you don't look at it she's
she's married look at it look at her
she's agreeing she's looking right
obviously you've learned from your
experience don't kick her while she's
down sorry she admitted to it it was a
bad time okay okay fair enough
financially emotionally
yeah
so if i ever get homeless i know who i'm
calling
one thing you didn't realize is that
she's learned from it yeah
did you go pick some other dumb rod
so you think you wouldn't do it again
well make this mistake with him
with a different guy
i mean
the fact that it was i mean is already a
problem i'd like i'd like for that
stand up
this is what i told my dad i was like
dad you need to just pick out my husband
for me
i'm full of that now my dad won't do it
though he says he's good he's like i got
bit like he's like i'm busy i got other
things to do
okay would you get into an arranged
marriage
yeah if i thought he was like i have to
find the guy attractive yeah because the
current method's not working is it
right so listen to this right so i i
propose a new method of relationship
right
so the new method is okay you don't you
get into a three-year contract with your
partner
okay three-year contract and within that
contract
everything
that you need and want in the
relationship is stipulated on by both
parties
in that contract and after the three
years if you want to renew it you renew
it if you want to go
you go you know what that's probably not
a bad idea it's better than the current
situation what happened because the
current situation is not working
marriages are failing the divorce rate
is up sky high most divorces are
initiated by women so women are clearly
not happy right so i propose
and people laugh at me i'm like listen
if we have insurance
and rolling contracts for everything in
our life why not have it for
relationships
because then that takes away the
naturalness of a relationship the
naturalist relationship is why the
divorce rate is so high and and why
women are initiated
i think that's just because people don't
know how to commit anymore to be honest
i think people struggle with true
commitment and knowing what it's like to
think it's the notion of i have fallen
out of love with you and that gives me
the um
permission to break up the marriage
divorce
people don't realize that in
relationships sometimes you're going to
fall a little bit out of love you're
going to get tired of your partner
sometimes and then there's going to be
there's going to be times where you fall
back into love and you you feel the
spark again yeah you know don't fall in
love
don't fall in love stand step into love
thank you thank you don't fall into it
love's an action yeah it's not a feeling
people tend to think that
listen i'm a man you're a man yeah we
understand that when we ch we choose to
love who we're going to love it's not oh
my god i fell into i
women do that men actually choose who
they're going to update listen i've been
in a place right where i've had three
women to choose from yeah
why are you laughing sorry she couldn't
laugh this one i've had i've been in a
place where i've had free women to
choose from and i've chosen the one that
i'm going to take
now all three of them just displayed all
of the qualities that
were going to be for a relationship but
i said you know what i'm gonna go there
yeah but we have that as well we've got
number one
but so it's so lovely
but the thing is but the thing is like
but the thing is like women i think okay
i think men do it too to be honest but
women like we choose bad boys yeah we do
like yeah be like we we're because we're
attracted i don't know who the hell we
is y'all struggling
like you told me yeah look at it but you
told me your ex was a serial cheater
like
but thank you
no but that's what i'm saying like like
because but we don't go into the
relationship knowing that these people
are bad yeah you do i i think um
no because like just like you had the
right it's like
that it wasn't good to go away well i
said from there
i said from the start that i see [ __ ]
for what it is once i see that red flag
i know what the [ __ ] it is so you left
the first time you cheated
he cheated yeah the first time no
because i was young and stupid no but
that's what i'm saying i'm speaking for
me now
i'm not speaking
chess jessica the point is it's just
that you're like it's we're attracted to
bad traits at times that's the whole
point it's not saying you can't learn
and pick better in the future
that's what sarah said we just gotta get
out of this vocabulary of falling in
love falling out of love because that's
just feelings okay i do
by our actions anyway three-year
relationships
nah you will not
the thing that you all don't seem to
realize is that you guys are
significantly older than us three years
for us i feel like
is a long time like in our twenties all
right two years yeah myself it's gonna
be better than the current situation at
the moment all right sorry all right
sorry i'm sorry for chester all right
don't worry about it go ahead it could
be all right
okay
the point i'm making is that it can be
tailor-made to whoever
is in the relationship you can say okay
let's do this for a year okay let's do
this for a year and a half you the two
of you can come together
make a contract because marriage is a
contract right make a contract that
benefits the both of you
and within that contract all the
stipulations are there whether you guys
have children within that time if you do
it's what sounds like marriage in the
1920s to me to be honest
women stuck around even though they were
getting by actually
i have a question for the panel do you
think that marriage worked before
because people didn't have the choice as
much to leave or because it actually
taught it totally and plus they focused
on their duty not on their feelings
marriage
marriage
yeah
i thought you were going down a
different path that's why i just had to
clarify but
pearl says that sex is a duty in
marriage
i do i do think it's a duty i feel like
i feel like you're putting your husband
in a bad spot if you don't give him sex
because i think myself in a bad spot if
you're not giving yourself sex no that's
true i agree with you sex is the most
natural thing in the world yeah but
girls like girls will like not give it
to their husbands like that's a common
thing i hear guys complain about this a
lot do you think that maybe that's
insecurities within that individual that
they're not happy within themselves
they're therefore not happy with their
bodies and therefore don't want anyone
else touching them perhaps um
i think partially but i think sometimes
it's because girls feel like they
settled and they didn't actually want
the guy they married
hence the reason why
the initiation of divorces is so high
amongst women okay i will say though i
think guys go after bad chicks too i
think it's like
i'll clarify this we may have sex with
bad chicks but we're not
not not i
i
define bad right now like like i feel
like y'all use a different definition
so what i mean is like toxic like guys
will act like they're above like going
for the toxic girl but oh come on i've
seen so many guys go after pretty toxic
women yeah and i don't i don't believe
for a second because they'll spend years
dating these girls chasing after these
girls
do you know why they're chasing after
them well yeah because they want to get
in the knickers yes
no no no but i'm talking no no no no
pathetic if you're going to spend years
that's what i'm saying in it
i'm just saying that everyone can speak
for yourself
there is a type of guy that i run into
they like girls that are a little bit
mean to them and i i you guys
degradations they're what we call them
they're not they're not but it's daddy's
no okay okay okay i'll give you an
example i'll give you an example
will smith had the option to pick a girl
he had the option to pick a girl that
was not mean to him you cannot say on
the fresh prince of bel air he did not
have the choice of a woman that did not
that did not treat him like that and i'm
saying as a woman i see this often there
is a certain type of guy a lot of times
they're from like a broken home that's
what i've noticed and i surveyed men on
this too over a thousand men voted in my
poll and they the majority said yes
there's a certain type of guy that likes
girls that are mean to him
your point of them being from a broken
home
yeah is a huge point yeah it's a huge
point because a lot of men that come
from broken homes who are mostly raised
by women
specifically in the black community who
are raised by women right who are have
mothers who are just
overbearing overbearing and you know
aggressive et cetera et cetera some
husbands well but right right yes they
will go for those types of women but
it's not even just like well but and
it's a large percentage of me it's like
more men than i think the manosphere
gives credit for because how many like
i'd say like half of our generation grew
up in a broken home like 50
both men and women yeah and so i think
like a lot of people don't have that
like model to choose from but i think
men are somewhat attracted to a girl
that's a little bit of a [ __ ] do you
know what yeah you might have touched on
something there pearl right because yeah
we speak about women having daddy issues
right but we never speak of men having
mommy issues
that's a good point i mean
mommy issues like you don't like there's
a lot of guys out here mommy issues uh
just an
update on some wild [ __ ] apparently asap
cheated on rihanna ah
it's a spring while she's pregnant with
this [ __ ] child does it
surprise us with a fenty footwear model
you like them toes
[Laughter]
i'm not hang on my neck hurts
but hang on if that's true
we don't know the ins and outs and the
dynamics of their relationship they
could have an open relationship well no
because cheating specifically means
but who said he was cheating did rihanna
say was cheating regardless she's
pregnant
i feel like and he's not getting any sex
so he's probably going to hold off
nine months
six men
again y'all are i swear to god y'all are
animals
that's what he's been saying y'all y'all
really just like to play up the primal
instinct man well because like it comes
from somewhere jessica
like like plenty of guys that do have
self-control and can hold themselves
right
for a um greater cause maybe they've got
a boxing match or they decided to become
a monk no because they just don't feel
like they have to function off of sex
you don't understand men that's a
problem
you don't understand men that's the
problem um so i don't understand the men
that i interact with on a daily basis
but you understand them better yes
because i'm a man yeah because they're
they're guys jessica babes
it's really sad that you all generalize
them right now but you know men have
very general things that we all kind of
take the boxes on okay we do okay i'm
not saying that it's right for if that's
true if asap rocky cheated on rihanna
i'm not saying it's right i'm not saying
that's right i'm saying
men are very sexually wired creatures
they are and
i understand because i was with my son's
mum for 10 years and when she was
pregnant
i didn't have sex with her for like
seven months
do you know what i mean but was i
looking at
the most random
woman on the street thinking oh yeah
because
the the the that's where you can only
speak for yourself though no but the but
i'm saying that
wasn't getting me if that makes sense
and there's a primal instinct why is it
that any products advertised to men
they've got to put a
sexy lady on there right like they
understand men's biology they don't
understand psychology they do
the problem is i think nowadays is that
women want men to be like women
and we're just not and so you you can't
be like not probably it's a double-edged
sword if we become like women you
despise us that's correct you're like oh
that guy's too soft oh look at that guy
oh he's a simple
you don't like men being like women
except for you by the way um
yeah we don't like it's so funny every
time he says something like wild to me
he's like
well it's more like it's it's more like
i think your reaction is just like very
pissed off and i'm trying like so no i
just can't laugh so yeah
your perspective now will be totally
different another five years time yes
great yeah yeah okay well guess what
we're not talking five years from now
we're talking right now so i'm going to
speak for myself right now
okay so right now you don't understand
men and how they think and what their
psychology is and you don't understand
women
and that's fair enough nice there we go
now
look at that we agreed on something okay
but the thing is when you were speaking
is that you when you were speaking out i
was understanding of myself and anyone's
understanding that you don't understand
how men think
and that's that's what i'm pointing out
i'm not trying to say that you're a bad
person or anything i'm just saying when
it comes to men and the way in which we
think and feel women generally don't
understand how men think and feel and
they try to make men into women i know i
just wish that sometimes with these
people doing all this transgender stuff
maybe they can do a trans
mind stuff so i'll put a girl into a
boy's mind and find out what we go
through like literally we think of sex
too you know
yeah men think of sex a lot yeah i'm
gonna read super chats really quick okay
guys all super chats are going towards
new camera equipment so i really
appreciate when you guys send these to
me i know you guys don't have to so
but but i appreciate it so keep sending
them
okay um two dollars from bowser why
why is the middle one so bitter
why are you so bitter why so bit at
cesco i'm not bitter
thank you for asking though okay um
next one six six keep rolling your eyes
well it's just like i just i feel like
sometimes
me and chess are gonna box off or
something
okay six dollars from mr k it's not easy
being a five four five four as a male i
personally i became black pilled myself
best personality it won't matter if most
women what is black people because i
don't understand oh black pill is when
they think it's over with because
they're too ugly they think they're too
ugly yeah i think there's no there's no
hope for them
oh yeah
so they literally are there's red for
everyone extreme hope for everyone yeah
um so black people was like i don't give
a [ __ ] about anything i just yeah yeah
burn the whole thing don't do don't do
black people guys don't do that no well
yeah they just get yeah they just
they just think let's see an example on
on youtube about someone um blackpill
look at nick fuentes
i don't know who that is
um best personality won't matter if most
women won't date short men um five
dollars
from oh
bowsey ask everyone at the table to rate
themselves out of ten
yeah but it's
out of ten for what for what for looks
like relative works yeah what do you
what sarah what do you give yourself out
of time
solid eight solid eight eleven eleven
i say eight eight you gotta put the
attributes so it's gotta be
no just looks no nope just looks
eight
i give myself a five
sorry
maybe six hearts even keep to the scale
though chesco of course not
you're just rebellious yes
okay i have very high standards for
myself and i know my worth um chris z
love the show here to keep the pregame
going thank you guys for real we cannot
keep this show going unless i get super
chat so i really appreciate it when you
guys send them to me um 10 pounds from
idris um the blonde is capping
um i bet she's gonna say her last
boyfriend abused her
wreck
but oh but she's total but she doesn't
like masculine guys are you okay
i think i'm okay i think which blonde is
stupid about chess girl yeah i think
it's superb um
sounds like man's got a lot to think
about when he goes to sleep tonight
um doug women are not are free to act on
their natural impulses and men are not
men are taught from a young age to
control our natural impulse pulses and
when women are not
what does that mean um what natural
impulses is
i think it's women with hypergamy and
men with sleeping around like men are
taught to control cheating where women
are are told you deserve the best even
if you don't do not do not actually yeah
i think there's a you see with hypergamy
right i think average men and average
women are missing each other
because i think a woman's average and a
man's average is different that's why
someone told me that a woman told me
that a woman's average
is different from a man's average
does that make sense now
okay so
so average woman
will want
an above average man
whereas an average man will be happy
with an average woman
does that make sense
i think it depends i think you have to
look at it like when you say you're
playing street fighter when you play
something like uh trick fighter you have
oh gosh
computer games yeah muscular analogy you
have speed agility six five that sort of
thing so maybe someone may be averaging
that looks like you gotta look at
somebody's personality-wise
you can see her she could be a mother of
my child she would look after our home
and men will compromise looks for that
right but you see like kevin samuels
right he gets quote unquote average
women yeah that have got i don't know
three kids for three different guys
calling this show
saying that they want
an above average man and it's like you
would you get an average guy calling a
show saying oh i want [ __ ]
[Music]
nicki minaj
no
he's like no you're not going to get
yeah because as men will say
it really really really more realistic
yeah but women as really well i think
it's because life is like harder to men
like i think like life like is harsher
because women still can get attention
and sex from above average guys
where men are not gonna get attention or
sex from anybody if they're average you
know i'm saying like even and so it kind
of inflates like girls ego on the other
side
like powell that was a there was a sorry
to cut the whole thing but there was an
episode that you done and you were
talking about
men it's okay for a man to leave his
wife if she put some weight oh yeah i
said leave the whales leave the whales
okay so
would so switching that yeah as a wife
would it be okay for you to leave a man
yeah
we have both whales male and female
i just think that you have a duty and
one of the duties is sustainable
this is why the contract i think
what's going on
no i swear to god because like you're
just gonna it depends i don't think you
should leave if you gain like i feel
like if you're truly in love you're not
gonna care maybe like i mean this is not
just word again
that's that shredded word that's a
feeling sorry go on chess go go on
chesco
i don't know what the hell you just said
but if you're genuinely in love with
somebody and you genuinely care about
them
maybe it just doesn't bother you that
much however for some other people
especially people who are like health
freaks right like me
i am a little bit of a health freak to
be honest so i would want someone who is
just as fit as me but that's because
like health problems run in the family
very common in the caribbean so you know
i want to instill healthiness within my
family and my future
kids caribbean dominican republic and
panama and almost technically central
america okay
i i agree but i think it's not just
about putting on the weight isn't it is
it about the mindset as well showing
that you're not caring for yourself
anymore so you're almost self-loathing
like you're
you've you've changed your mentality
well i think it's disrespectful to your
partner like because you because you
forget about the partners disrespectful
to yourself agree if you let yourself go
you know like you but you also represent
like i mean i think that's kind of
embarrassing to a guy like if he dates a
girl and she gains like a hundred pounds
hundreds all right now that's why
that's what i was talking about yeah
[Music]
so there's 14 pounds to a stone so 14
into 100 goes
what eight times 70 times yeah
yeah
yeah but the weight issue could be more
the fruit of a much deeper issue it
could be yeah it could be
but like this is this is what usually
girls do when they're wrong they find
the exception to the rule rather than
the rule the majority of people gain
weight because they're lazy i'm sorry
it's because they eat too much and they
don't exercise enough
and this is coming i've been over 200
pounds and it was because i ate too much
and i did not exercise enough like it
was my own fault but like you're looking
for the exception rather than the right
thing at least you've got the
self-awareness to to admit that yeah men
find that we'll find that attraction i
love eating yeah it's great
the fact that you would if you make a
mistake you will own up to it and men
general will find that attractive
because men in general
are more forgiving than women
i would say that do you think so yeah i
think because you'll remember i think
women are more confusing
because you know what i'll be honest i
swear they're going to forget more than
they're going to be like why did you say
that on october 3rd 2008 yeah
[Music]
it takes a little bit more time for us
as women to learn how to get past that
kind of stuff that's what i'm saying
because man we're more forgetful we'll
be like yeah like you you kind of forgot
something happened unless it really hurt
you you know but for us it sometimes it
is the little things that hurt us yeah
that's what i think man
it's forgiving because it was
forgetfulness
i agree with you because women leave
more but i also think it goes back to
like the consequences thing like are men
more forgiving or do they have to be
because there's more consequences for
them not because if they leave they
might lose half their [ __ ]
i think when a woman leaves she's done
like when a woman leaves she's done i
think she was done she's done something
at the time she was done six months
before
at the very minimum we're done two weeks
before the end of the relationship
bare minimum literally yeah okay so the
question becomes why are so many women
saying that they're done nowadays why
because we're fed up with being we're
figuring out also
is the illusion of choice do you know
what i think it is i think women were
sold why is it an illusion disagree i
think
it's the syndrome of the grass is always
greener no but probably always
yeah
is that grass
no no no it's the guys it's the small
percentage of guys that can do that that
do i think it's not it's not the
majority of men because the majority
like one in three men under 30 are a
virgin
i'm telling you it's not you know why
y'all be safe you know what i think
women were sold a lie
they were sold the hollywood dream of
what a relationship was they were so the
disney dream of what a relationship the
notebook and then what happens is when
they get into these relationships they
realize oh this is this is not what it
was this is not what it's supposed to be
and they leave men i think are more
realistic which is why it's women who
most of the time who are initiating
divorces also i would say this though
why is it sorry let me say this point
why is it that women the knowledge of
hollywood tells that women can all be
princesses that means you'll gotta be um
um
but you're not
so the fact that the hollywood tells you
you're a princess but the definition of
a princess i'm a queen
but i i also think it's supply and
demand
right i think men probably would leave
more if they felt like they could leave
and get someone better no because men
when men find out when men choose the
woman that they're going to be with
if they say i do men generally
this is me
this is me for like all right cool i'm
fine this is me for life i'm good right
a lot of women hypergamy comes into uh
play right and they're like ah you know
what maybe i can get something better
than this because uh
and real and truly once you divorce a
man
and you've got a couple of children
it's not looking like what you think
it's going to be looking like once you
leave that guy it's and it's not it's
what you've created in your head and
that perfect relationship that you're
going to get yeah i mean i think that's
right maybe in that instance but i think
in the beginning stage when you're when
you're dating men are
more reluctant to commit in the
beginning because they they do think the
grass is greener but then what tends to
happen is they get a partner and they're
like i'm not sure i'm on the fence
and then whatever it ends and then they
realize that a couple months i'm like oh
actually the the grass isn't is
ingredient in my experience yeah the
knowledge i like to use is chewing gum
it tastes good for after all after this
sugar comes out you spit it out
so you spit me out no i'm just saying no
no no no no you're waiting have you guys
no um like like the streets the streets
aren't that great basically i just want
to ask have any of you guys started
watching the ultimatum on netflix
so it's basically a show about couples
um i don't know how many couples there
are like maybe like eight of them let's
say
and one of the partners in the couple
gives them an ultimatum it's you have to
marry me now or i leave now
and
in the process they get to date all
these other people within these other
couples so like let's say you and i were
together and you two were together
i could go and date him and you can go
date him
and you wouldn't date manchester
yeah you right
and if we end up vibing enough and we
both feel like this relationship is
worth it i can go ahead and leave him
and we get married instead yeah just
because the ultimatum was not met by my
original partner yeah so i did a show
yeah on marriage and i think marriage
has become a joke
and that actually that show i've never
seen it but it actually shows that
marriage has become a joke because
marriage is now a tv show
people don't give a damn about that
you've got 90 day fiance you've got what
is it
i'm sorry love is blind
is a joke and this is one of the reasons
or it's maybe a symptom of the fact that
marriage is not being taken seriously
we can now make a reality tv show out
but i think the problem is that the
standard of marriage has changed so many
times like marriage initially started
off as
here's my daughter give me a dowry yeah
and then people were like let's turn it
nigeria
the only difference like i really think
it's just the takeaway of consequence
because we added birth control that
changed marriage forever because you
take away the consequence of like
getting pregnant and like dating so
before like you had to get married
younger otherwise like how many women
started getting rights as well like we
didn't need to marry a man in order to
have a bank account or be able to do any
sort of things with finances as well
most of the time women ended up in these
marriages because we needed something
you know yeah are you a feminist
why does that matter no i'm just asking
because you're speaking like a feminist
no i'm speaking about history yeah but
i'm awesome if you don't know basic
history
it's just the way you like yeah
i believe in equal rights and equal
lefts that doesn't make me a feminist it
just means that i think everybody says
the feminists have the religious
equality
feminists have the legitimate complaint
but the wrong solution mm-hmm yeah
yeah yeah that's why i would say what
happened yeah feminism yeah
because there was a legitimate complaint
like for example you couldn't open a
bank account without your husband's
right
for example the divorce laws was if
there was a divorce didn't just say this
eighteen seventeen hundreds this will
agree with the feminists everything went
to the man so obviously they had to be a
pen and obviously that caused resentment
and that's what caused the reaction
that's where you had the sub-rejects
movement and stuff but obviously now
it's gone well it's gone away or it's
gone way over yeah like that so in the
same way i sort of agree i just say this
to you a few months back that uh in some
ways i do agree with the alamani rules
in principle in the sense that
no no no let me let me explain
let me explain let me explain okay why
was initially
initiated because if a whoop if a man
did leave a woman the woman was
obviously destitute so they've put this
law in place to think okay if the man
decides to do the ultimate thing and
leave a woman the woman doesn't become
obviously definitely how do we get to
them now but now it's gone
no it's gone way overboard because i
think their initial role there was a
good logic behind it
because now divorce is a business to you
you can marry into you can marry a man
yeah the the height the most the richest
women in america are divorcees
it's a business divorce is a business
sometimes i think that like
i put this there should be no laws
around it at all
and like like around marriage yeah like
like we just make it a business like
like like take the government out of it
completely
because like i feel like everyone just
has to deal with their own consequences
so like if you pick someone that's going
to leave you the second like you say the
government out of it because the
government needs to register who's
getting married so they can make good
choices in terms of building
infrastructure when they're doing census
and stuff so that needs to be government
needs to be involved okay like can't you
do it without the legal ramifications
like there's no aloe vera
i can definitely agree with that yeah
like because now women can work like i
said right that's the thing like at
least i can speak for america because i
can't speak for other countries one
thing about america they're going to
make everything a business
and they managed to make [ __ ]
a business
they managed to make colleges a business
like they
i don't know they're just the kings of
that [ __ ] i can't say much about that
but
you know they can see that they can take
some money out of that they're like oh
your joint household income is so and so
when you guys are married this is your
marital status perfect we'll take out
these taxes like oh you have how many
kids together
this is what we're gonna take out of
this like
bring back incentive if you get married
you get a tax break of 100 grand
100 grand
you don't pay no time i just say rework
the relationship model because the
current one is not working no i don't i
don't like the three years
i'm feeling like that ain't working for
me i'm here you hang on you think
tomorrow
as much as you know
about the manuscript much as you know
about statistics about divorce and right
you think that this is to get rid of the
workers no i said get rid of the laws
like why do we need alimony why do we
need like do we need like i need to
bring up it should have been already
obvious that someone would have their
own [ __ ] and you have your own but
there's a there's like there's
there's a difference i think between
like
i see that's hard because i do i could
see prenups because that's something you
agree to like beforehand right right
yeah but
okay so but that should be standard from
the start hello you know the statistics
right yeah you know marriages are not
working they're breaking down
right well you know what i think though
i think like marriage didn't necessarily
work before i think we just have more
opportunity to leave because how many
grandparents were separated that was
really common like people say oh it was
a different generation
but my grandparents were separated they
were married they were married for a
very long time but there and i i could
say
like that's so common so now what's the
solution then what's that i don't know
i'm not god
right because if i see certain things
going a certain way i'm like okay cool
how can we fix that yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i've been talking about the light
before and it's the lights out we're
gonna fix that yeah so i'm saying the
current model clearly isn't working
right okay it's not it's not working we
all agree yeah right okay so do we need
a new model are we gonna stick with the
old model
i i
i'm sorry
that's why men make the frigging
decision
we need to fix some stuff totally
totally i was going to bring it back to
what pearl said regardless a lot of
people just stayed in marriage just
because it's easier than leaving
convenience especially um when you bring
religion to it right like christians
they don't believe in divorce at least
hardcore christians don't believe in
divorce
some christians do believe in the world
that's why i said hardcore christians
when you're when you're going into like
orthodox yeah so same thing with
possibly but now the question is is that
a bad thing because it's every study is
going to tell you that it's better for
children to have both parents in the
home you put your kid at every
statistical disadvantage if you don't
have both parents in the home
so is it is it necessarily a bad thing
if it's if i think it's better off for
the parents to be separated i could be
biased just because i came from a
divorced parent household but it is much
better than letting your kids sit there
and watch two parents who don't love
each other anymore weather the storm
just for them and then the child grows
up thinking that they're the burden
like it happens very often no love is
always sacrificial it's not about what
you'll feel yeah but if you're if you
don't love anymore then when did your
parents get divorced love is not a
feeling it was just the mistakes that
we're making i was about seven years old
you're about seven love isn't action
love is not a feeling what do you think
about that
if love is an action
if we started seeing it as an action not
so much a feeling do you think we'd be
in this people cannot weather those
storms though a lot of people are weak i
hate to say it some people do not have
the strength to stay in the same
household as their partner right and
even look at that
for their child it's duty though
because like i said if i'm married with
kids there's some days i don't feel like
going to work can i say to my family i
don't feel like going to work today this
stuff but that's why i do it because
i've got a greater goal
duty no i i like i agree with you
because it's not why i just feel like
once you have because people always ask
me would i stay with a cheater and i
always say
no unless there were kids
because once you have kids it's not
about you i can totally understand that
however because i don't have children i
cannot make that
right you know comment right but what i
can say is from the perspective of
somebody who you said
even though you didn't have children
right huh you said they were cheating
even though you didn't have when i was
17 right is the difference here you
gotta understand
you know i
grew up watching people cheat on each
other all the time yeah okay so i'm
thinking like oh so yeah that might that
must happen
exactly my perception was skewed on that
however i started to grow up a little
bit more and i started to mature a
little bit more and understand this is
not how it's supposed to be
right cheating should not be normalized
and like i said when it comes to parents
staying together i think my parents
tried their absolute hardest to stay
together for me but i was seeing a lot
more
no i have two siblings okay okay um i
think somebody but they're significantly
younger than me and they're both half
siblings like sorry yeah there's one
from my mom's side and one for my dad's
side so they don't have to deal with
what i dealt with growing up they're
actually watching a happy relationship
or marriage now and i would much rather
prefer that they deal with that like i
i'm happy for that i think sometimes
what trips us up is our definition what
love is in greek i think it has the best
it has some great definition you have
eros eros othello
and agape agape is the sacrificial love
it's the love that doesn't expect
african return the closest one that we
can have from a human perspective is the
love our mother has for a child
but scripturally scripture says when the
husband's supposed to love his wife
you're supposed to god pay your wife
love you know unconditionally
in a way that um sacrificially even
though she's not returning it back to
you you you need to give that and i
think if people more focused on that
that might heal in my culture we call
that idiot
maybe maybe but maybe that made it
but both parties have to do that i think
that's what i'm just trying to get for
just knowing you don't love somebody
if it's not returned
that's a fella but that's not the love
you're meant to have for y'all
i think everybody has different
standards and definition of love and
what sacrifices for your child but not
for your part for what uh for someone
from a scriptural perspective that's the
one you're meant to have that's the one
it's not dependent on um feelings or if
it's reciprocal that's the sacrificial
of you meant to have that's what i'm
saying scripturally for a woman you're
supposed to have sacrificial love for
for your wife yes
that's christ is the wife supposed to
have sacrificial love for husbands yes
it's supposed to be interesting yeah
this is what i'm saying it's not about
feelings that's why i hate this notion
of i am in love with someone i'm out of
luck with someone that's it's all mixed
up it's so so populish we see this in
the soap operas we think oh we're gonna
do it it's disney stuff yeah disney
stuff yeah love's always a duty
yeah but i just think that's like
there's until a certain point i do think
i i'm and i'm i think it's rare but i
think there are some instances where
like
you should leave like your wife gaining
150 pounds
my goodness cause then you know what
because you know what that's child abuse
because then you're teaching your kids
so you wouldn't have obesity
obesity
yes
sorry
look at look at because that's child
abuse you raise your kid in an
environment where you're teaching them
to be obese
child abuse sorry it's that you're
giving them horrible habits the rest of
their life
still hungry
yeah it's probably because you're wrong
okay i'm going to read you call me now
i'm going to read super chats okay um
dion lewis love your wife as yourself
two dollars um
okay thank you um five dollars from
plenty more manny thoughts on something
patrice said that feminism is a
conspiracy to move women from the
household to the workforce to double the
amount of people taxed
oh [ __ ]
that's a concept oh i never do some
research i never thought about that
um two dollars from eat godly yes keep
the government out of the marriage
business
1999 from mgtow by logic no ma'am you
have it exactly backwards dowry is the
bride's family paying not receiving
funds you got to get your facts straight
i don't know anything about a dowry you
know that i could have just made a
mistake when i was speaking but my
apologies i don't know why you have to
be crying and bitching in the comments
like that but i hope you find god i
don't i don't think he's
damn i don't think i don't think i made
a mistake i'm not gonna lie to you but i
think he did because technically you are
giving your daughter because they are
worth a certain amount of money or goats
or whatever the hell they was doing back
then yeah yeah and that was the family
receipt because you know usually the
family of like the bride was poor yeah
yeah you know so they had to receive
some sort of money out of
the groom's family so i'm not really
maybe it's just a cultural difference
maybe in a different culture
but you're right on that one so then who
pays for the wedding in these days and
times and should demand these days yeah
should the men pay for the wedding um
well from what i was raised up on it's
that the father of the bride pays for
the wedding
that's the diary
huh nah but that's like a backwards
dowry though because if it's the father
of the president
giving
i don't know okay um what happens to
this day though shockingly really yeah
yeah yeah i don't i don't know anything
about that stuff no one in my family's
gotten married yet except my brother but
why are you not married pal what's going
on
well that's what they ask me every day
yeah i'm sure that's really oh my god
yeah oh my god i'm like i'm doing this
i'm doing the [ __ ] thing
actually the matchmaker can help you out
like i'm trying okay
my family's on the opposite end of the
spectrum for that one okay you missed
the point on the impulses thing many
impulses men have are suppressed
aggression assertiveness natural
promiscuity
non-productive emotion judgment and
logic these days um next one eat godly
you skip my super chat um it's probably
it's probably for a reason
i'm gonna be honest i'm sorry um jeremy
wilkes five dollars no
you didn't even have a no
thank you she's just giving me money to
give me money
um okay ten dollars from doug mpa
oh i we already did that one earlier
okay that was all of them thank you guys
literally all super chats are going
towards a new camera if you want to see
me like close up if you don't get enough
of me now she said if you want to see my
five out of 10 ads
that's the way to do it yes if you want
to see the 11 out of 10.
i'm only here once in a while
unfortunately
you might see me more
yeah so send send super chats you really
think you're 11 out of 10 absolutely
do you think you're a little bit
delusional there i don't care
it's better to live in delusion anyway
i'm like
she'll grow out of it
you know i won't how do you know
23 and i'm gonna stay that way
do you feel like women get less
attractive the older they get no so it's
black women aged like fine wine so sorry
i can't you think 80 you think at 80
you'll be as hot as you want i think 80
i'll be an old woman
well that's what i'm saying so like i
think your the metrics or your
attractions will change so for example
if you're five in looks but your
personality is you know eight that'll
put you up because you're giving the man
peace that's what i'm really about a man
wants
ultimately i think men age quite well
i think men once they age
if a man's 40
right
he could
he said that on purpose because he 40.
and i look good
why because black don't crack no but i'm
saying if a man's 40 he could think
about
seeing a woman in her 20s maybe late 20s
right if a woman's 40
i don't know about seeing a man in his
20s
don't you feel it's nature's way to
balance the skill meaning that men's
women's value is when they're young
you know in terms of fertility and stuff
like that right i mean there's a reason
why
balance is well we get the chance once
we get older
we're more mature we're more wise we
could more forward think and this is
better
and in this society
men don't become like quote-unquote
millionaires until they're 40s a lot of
women these days people are these days i
think you're gonna get no i think you're
gonna get younger millionaires than ever
because of social media they already do
so yeah we're running the market in
general men become
excuse me more successful yeah
yeah you're right yeah yeah yeah but i
mean but i'll challenge you on that one
if you get money young
it's like afflicts money athletes are
not necessarily millionaires because a
lot of have a lot of liabilities but to
manage their money no there's
millionaires coming from like drop
shipping from like like just
like they'll they'll start when they're
like 15 16 like in high school learning
like drop shipping on shopify and that's
a real world skill
i like i genuinely think you're going to
see the youngest like ever
millionaires
advantage of being so technologically
advanced right that like unfortunately
the older generations most of the time
can't keep up with this kind of stuff so
we have that advantage because a lot of
corporations are looking for people that
can keep up with technology can do
statistics and social marketing and all
that kind of stuff so we kind of run the
market right now well and what i i think
you're probably your point is that's
like real success isn't overnight and
like and that's true like you can get
money quick but like money that goes
quick comes quick but i just or comes
quick goes quick but like i i think
we're just gonna see younger and younger
people with real skills because like you
can start learning [ __ ] on youtube at
like wow
the highest paid youtuber as a kid
but then don't you see that i don't know
some kid that does toy reviews or
something i think i've seen him yeah
oh maybe not anymore but at one point
but his parents are managing that money
yeah
but there will be a point whereby
you're not going to get that as much
money as you did before like for example
10 years ago you probably could have
made thou hundreds of thousands just
having maybe 100 000 subscribers on
youtube you can't do that anymore so
because the market's becoming so
saturated right but it's also up to you
to know
what is demanded in this market though
if you're truly about it you're going to
know exactly what to put out there it's
hard to see because what's demanded is
more
wrenchier stuff but then again that has
long-term consequences as well mm-hmm so
women know that their looks are fading
they know that as they get older
men generally
don't worry about
their looks fading
like women do do you know what i mean
and and because that's like a
subconscious conversation that women
understand that men
are attracted to the way
i think i don't think i mean i don't
think most men age well to be honest i
think most people like i'm gonna like no
but no seriously the majority of people
are overweight and most people get
fatter the older they get in gen men too
like
so i mean i i wouldn't know anything
about that but yeah there we go there's
a sign no i think that's confidence but
i
i think that's neglect
what am i neglecting here your skincare
routine what's wrong with my skin
you want me to count the blackheads go
go for it i'm kidding i'm kidding i'm
kidding okay
i'm kidding i'm kidding
they're going
and i'm counting yours too
you can't spot a blackhead from a mile
away but nice try
if you don't know what skincare is do
you how can you spot a blackhead my
skincare routine is
washing my soap and water
black soap and shea butter that's my
skincare routine
okay um we just got a bunch more super
chats thank you guys um matthew
matthew g
i'm sorry gomes go it's okay the world
you're the word you are looking for is
hedonism this is how we make choices in
the west marriage works in third world
countries because there is no feminism
and they
understand it's about duty and
responsibility not hedonism mgtow by
logic no i'm not wrong you are wrong i'm
sorry i don't know anything about
dowries i'm sorry
the dowry is on her family's paying but
keep talking the nonsense this is on the
internet forever i'm sorry we're not
experts in dowries why is this man
crying so hard damn um did mommy not
feeding pearl can you ask the one in the
middle oh why do you why do you think
you're an 11 if like being at 10 is
you're perfect
so do you do you think you're perfect
no i think there's beauty
in imperfection
you know perfection is not uh why are
you talking over me no i'd say there's
glamorous beauty and there's a
difference anywhere just got chilled i
believe that i'm an 11 out of 10 just
because i can and i'm allowed to yeah
that way and no i genuinely believe
perfect
i was not done talking
um i genuinely believe that perfection
is not real but there's beauty and
imperfection and i think no like you're
you're you're very attractive like i
think you're like i think you're
attracted
but no no
so what i'm saying like like to me i
would never say i'm a 10 because like a
10 is like perfect and i don't think i'm
perfect so i i get like is that
but we were saying looks wise right yeah
and i genuinely see myself as genuinely
beautiful i genuinely see myself as
someone who is a goddess because at the
end of the day
society is what decides on
beauty standards right right and i can i
don't have to follow that beauty
standard right i genuinely believe that
i'm beautiful yeah well and i'm not
taking that away from you i just like i
just couldn't i just couldn't i just
could never say like i wouldn't say
you're
perfect do you wanna you know i don't
yeah yeah and that's and that's what i
said eleven out of ten i'm just playing
around but yeah i think i'm really ten
out of ten like genuinely i feel like
i'm a ten out of ten yeah i take care of
myself what has given you that uh my
looks
we were only talking about love
we weren't talking about personality or
skill or anything like that is is that
based on the way people have treated you
throughout your life no this is based on
how i was raised and how i view myself
and how i've worked hard to see the
beauty that i deserve to see
so you worked so you see an 11 out of 10
beauty i wouldn't bro it's a joke
okay okay but we could say i'm saying
that yeah yeah like i just said i
consider myself a 10 out of 10 for sure
so you think you're up there with so who
would you see in like the media that's
like a 10 out of 10 women why are we
going based off of media people no like
why does that matter well because
on society's beauty standards and what
they think of the 10 out of 10. well
because that like society's beauty i
don't give a [ __ ] about society that's
the key here is that i i have my own
viewpoint right like okay so who would
you classes are 10 out of 10
apart from yourself
well because like
in order in order to scale someone 1-10
someone has to not be a 10. right so so
like fully agree with that yeah and so
but we asked
what i think i am what she thinks is
what you think you are i'm not going
based off of anybody else except for
what i see in the mirror right so but
then like that almost wouldn't be a
scale that like because then you have no
way to mess with [ __ ] right okay so
it's like your way of rebelling against
the scale almost forget rebellion it's
just genuinely how i feel right and i'm
not saying like i like again like i
think i think you're beautiful yeah but
it's just but it's beautiful
it's just for you to say that you're a
five out of ten right but i just think i
live like in greece
because you're trying to i'm not making
a comparison
in her own right she is beautiful so you
would say she's a tendon yes but like
you're in her own right but i just think
if i was if i was a 10 i would have had
modeling
[Music]
i would have had modeling contracts by
now i would have had people i would have
had results to show that i would have
had nfl nba players but remember that is
all based on beauty standards that are
set by that's based on reality
that's society that's reality
and like but i don't see the same way
that other people do though yeah i asked
the question do you think there's an
objective beauty standard yes
can you describe objective to me as in
like what the baseline okay something
like an objective society beauty
standards so for example art
is there good art or is all art the same
i feel like that's kind of different
because art art is also something that's
all about perspective but enjoy
subjective yeah it's subjective yeah but
in in
in
if you look at medieval buildings
especially americans notice this when
they come here they love our ancient
architecture right compared to their
style architecture so there is a
standard that's like a stick figure
versus like picasso
i guess um when it comes to that
you know art is something that you put
time and skill and detail into
i can't really say the same for people
no because my point is that as as
generally human beings can identify
what's beauty and what's not
in the society yeah but even the society
has a standard of beauty yeah exactly
yeah because we can identify a good
architect a good
uh beautiful building than a standard
one yeah we will our brain
again that's just what we consider
aesthetically pleasing like
when it comes to people i can't really
do that because but you can do it to
yourself though we can choose how we
build a building but we can't choose how
we look that much we can only do so much
to our appearance to change ourselves
and then into the and fit into the
beauty standards on top of the fact that
the beauty standard has changed so much
over the last i want to say
disagree agree with that because you
look at the kings and when they had all
their concubines you can definitely
guarantee they had to be the finest
women in the land be the king's
concubine being part of the king's
cottage so there had to there's always
been a whether we like it or not an
objective standard that this man of
power
i think the reason for this conversation
like myself in india having is that
there seems to be in these days and
times a
female delusion
about how
you view yourself and i think men
generally are a little bit more
realistic as the way they view
themselves okay now my question is why
are men so obsessed with humbling women
why is it why does it hurt so much to
watch a woman love themself and
genuinely believe that they're 10 out of
10 even though they're not according to
society's standards i'll give you an
answer to that one i think it's more of
a reaction because they've tried to do
the simpish behavior be the nice guy and
they've just been flawed for it so
they're overreacting to it that's
probably what's happening i don't think
it's that i think that when you interact
with people right
you generally try to gauge the type of
person that they are right
and so
people can gauge me and say this guy's a
little bit sarcastic this guy's
this guy yeah
and i get that you know what i'm saying
but when i engage other people i
too
try to gauge the way in which they see
themselves like oh that person's a
little bit then that person's a little
bit whatever it is right
and too many times in these days and
times when people are engaging in with
people they're saying ah
she thinks that she's all that well do
you know what i mean like women
generally tend to think that they are
higher right than other people and it's
like well can't just calm down a little
bit but that's that's egotistical versus
just confidence i think what it is i
think it has to be if you have a
actually a really illusion i actually
really want to hear what you probably
have to say real quick
question for you
so if you if you um if you had a guy
coming around and saying like i'm a like
a 10 in terms of my income so in terms
of like like i get money i get this
bread
even though he's like broke would you
would you would you not would you not
like look at him like a little
delusional
i probably would but that's because we
can actually gauge that properly right
right remember beautifully
we can actually measure properly due to
i'm not done talking
damn
we can't properly get we can properly
gauge wealth though according to the
living standards of whatever state or
country we live in well could you argue
and say that if a [ __ ] got two
dollars in his bank account he says he's
a 10 out of 10 i'm gonna be like what
you don't like that can you argue is it
not society that's saying that two
dollars eight in a
could you not the guy not argue that no
but we've actually we've actually played
we're walking away
you got two dollars
actually are able to put a value on that
but we
as a society do not do not have a right
to put a gauge on beauty but they do
chesca but that's no that's [ __ ] i
never said that there was anything wrong
with that at the end of the day i'm just
saying that i can't i don't see it like
that
that's why i'm saying like i feel like
like when you say that it's not that
because you actually think you're
perfect it's because it's because you
think like you don't like society's like
beauty standards and it's kind of like
your way of rebelling i think i'm
beautiful but then people i didn't like
you
question me on it
and the only way that i can answer is
the way that they can understand because
when i start saying like because i think
i'm beautiful but they're like why
why why do you think you're 10 out of
10. what is it that makes you a 10 out
of 10. and it's like
well but like the thing is like it's
weird though because i feel like girls
do this to guys all the time like i
think if also i think that girls like if
a guy says oh i can get girls i can get
[ __ ]
and like we don't think he can we'll
humble him
and it's kind of like we will that's
what i'm saying like even even you kind
of like we're trying to do that to sarah
earlier
it's a double standard i think it was a
little selective
it was a little outlandish for him to
ask me what i rate him because at the
end of the day i was talking to you
all right what'd you rate me what'd you
rate me i think you're allowed to
believe whatever you want to play no no
no wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait greet each other
write each other rate each other oh
jesus go rate each other okay
rate each other
she's thinking i don't want to give him
too much gas
she's trying to go through the whole
thing going
my neck hurts
please
all right
you mm-hmm for your age mm-hmm
no no no no i'm an eight okay cool okay
now rate her
had five really you give her a five now
i'm joking
i can't get mad at you you're an eight
you're you're an eight okay
but genuinely you're not you're not an
11.
i'm trying to speak
i genuinely cannot get upset at the way
that other people feel about my physical
ability yeah i should make sure i'm not
done talking
oh my goodness maybe put down the
alcohol for a good minute
anyway i genuinely can't get upset when
other people feel the way that they do
about my appearance whether they think
i'm a one or a ten because beauty is in
the eye of the beholder
like for me it's like facial symmetry so
i actually like agree with what he gave
you like i would probably give you seven
eight because your face is very
symmetrical okay and i bet like you
probably had a modeling contract at some
point i
i was a freelance model i haven't um
that's what i'm saying because like i
rate people eight to ten and you could
get a model i i don't really give seven
so i think like if you could i don't i
try not to because i like it's based on
someone else came up with this but like
i just thought it made sense so like
eight to ten is like you could make
money off your looks five six you can't
that's why i don't give myself above a
set like above a six that's why i say
five six because i feel like i'm more
pretty cute yeah you could be a six card
a lot of modeling agencies have been
looking for people with more distinct
features right even a little less
symmetry than usual especially within
the last like for women though for women
though no not even because um like i do
a lot of research because i do want to
model um but i have to be very careful
about what modeling agency that i do go
into because they have to be inclusive
enough and open-minded enough now if you
look at um a lot of the top modeling
agencies like four models or wilhamina
you're going to see like the same beauty
standard that we've seen for the last
like 10 to 15 years right like usually
the women have long hair
you know the face is very symmetrical
they might have like olive skin or
lighter skin and you might only see like
one or two dark-skinned models you know
um you're gonna usually see the same
things but now new age modeling agencies
are going for a different beauty
standard where people have a little bit
more of an alternative look which is
what i i would say i'm closer to having
an alternative look so you'll see people
more with like gapped teeth or like
crooked teeth you'll see people with
like maybe an eye like that's a little
lower than the other vitiligo you'll see
the piercings more tattoos all that kind
of stuff
but like my point is i think that's more
like marketing to women i don't think
that's actually like like i i just feel
like we all know who's attractive like
when someone walks into a room like i
could tell you if they're attractive or
not i think everyone's gonna generally
have the same idea so no matter how much
political correct modeling is out there
generally if you're looking for the
audience that you're targeting they're
gonna they're gonna decipher that they
may tell you it's like oh she's
beautiful in front of their men but deep
down i mean people put lizzo up on her
like pedestal like oh my god she's
amazing it's like
she's just a fat woman
and i don't even think it's like
humbling like like like you because
you'll say why are you so obsessed with
humbling women right and like even with
lizzo that's what the man of spheres
like favorite person to humble is i
think
but like it's like sad to her because
like honestly i think she looks kind of
dumb sometimes because people allow her
to like live in this delusion where
she's like walking at 300 pounds with
her butt out and nobody like checks her
like you don't you don't think that's
kind of mean
personally like i said i think everybody
that's where delusion comes in i think
everybody has a right to believe that
they are beautiful in their own right
because at the end of the day we can't
really do much to change our looks and
even if we do it's like a damned if you
do damned if you don't kind of society
like if we could get
all liposuction done and our face done
and reconstructed but people are still
going to find something wrong right when
it came to lizzo right like i
was upset when she did do the whole like
when she would like was courtside at the
nba game and like her ass was out right
not because of her size or who she is as
a person or whatever i was more so upset
because that was not the time to do that
like right the kids be watching
basketball too you know like this this
was inappropriate if she was doing it at
her own concert at her own leisure we
can't say much because at the end of the
day that's what she wants well i mean
it's okay if she wants to do that i just
think like
people like they're li like the people
around her are lying to her and gassing
her up like
we're friends right so i would if we
went out to a bar and i was and i wore
something where like i just it makes me
look heavy
right i and you don't say anything to me
like are you a real friend
let's see but that that's the difference
though is the
personal relationship versus just people
on the internet that like to idealize
and idolize
celebrities
they like to have someone to look up to
and unfortunately women get to be
delusional do you not understand like
they get to be like they get to be
lizzle well i think men don't get to be
that delusional exactly because like
because women were like yeah girl you go
ahead listen as a guy if you came out
and
guys will check up a guy and say bro
like
yeah bro yeah you've got a bug in your
nose as well you know what i'm saying
like just get rid of women
tend and i said this on your show before
women will lie to other women
knowing that they're lying to other
women and gas that woman up like lizzo
and then she'll be out in the public eye
and then she'll be like oh i want a high
value man it's like
bro like love you're about 300 pounds
right he's not looking for you right you
know he's not looking for him like you
and you might believe that you are this
11 out of 10 woman right well
but you're not well and it's and to me
like i'm just someone like i'd rather
someone be honest and i and i think like
your point is like you think like women
should be confident because we can't
always change how we look yeah and so i
think that's like the point like that
women are like really trying to get
across exactly but like like men are
like it's okay to be confident but
like you guys are delusional at some
point and i think there's somewhere in
like a middle ground where you can still
be confident in what you have you know
what i mean but again like that still
brings it back to beauty standards right
like there's a couple of countries in
the world where they believe women who
are fat are the most beautiful yes like
they fully believe that because
i can't remember the name of the country
literally like that's the thing like
beauty standard really is something
that's created by society like at some
point um you know like we only saw women
with fair skin blonde hair blue eyes as
the beauty standard for a long time
but then why but then why delude
yourself about the society in which you
live in you don't live in that society
where women are who are fat yeah are the
beauty standards you don't live in that
society you live because i don't live in
it doesn't mean i can't acknowledge it
no no i acknowledge it too but that's my
point is
that is proof
that beauty standards really are just
created
they're subjective i get it exactly but
the one in which you live in like lizzo
she's convinced herself that she is a uh
who whatever and it's like in this
society's beauty sanders you ain't that
my dear and so why do people start
gassing her up saying no you are that
and it's like you are literally feeding
because why are you allowed to say that
she's not because you are allowed to
humble a man right if a man bro i never
said i was allowed to have an element
of men yeah women are allowed i don't
believe i don't believe any of us have a
right to humble anybody at the end of
the day because we are all we are all
just human and we are all living life
we're just trying to figure out i just
think it's like a reality man like
that's not honestly i just think it's
like real like i'd rather
but your reality is different from mine
but
you guys keep forgetting perception is
everything in this world like there's a
reason why i study psychology everything
is perception you guys feel like reality
is no this person is unattractive and
this person is attractive and this is
the beauty standard that we set but
there's hella countries and people out
there that do not but that's right but
that's the mind okay
who's more attractive lizzo
or
beyonce yeah
but do you see how that is still a
subjective question no matter how you
put it but i i don't think it is i think
they're both beautiful in their own
right because they're asking based on
society's perception
a majority of people say that beyonce is
more beautiful therefore i should say
beyonce right i would say the best
answer for this from a biblical
perspective we're beautiful in the sense
that we are created in the image of god
from a horizontal perspective how god
sees human beings but also you have to
bear in mind how do we see each other
from the um not from the vertical but
from the horizontal yeah men to men
that's where i would say so vertically
how god sees us yes i agree with you we
are beautiful because we are god's
creation created in his image but the
horizontal from man to man will differ
and i will agree and you have to agree
that there is
nine times out of ten down to
probability there will be a standard
yeah
that's because we create it and that
doesn't mean that i'm gonna go against
it and bark about it and cry about it no
i i'm fully aware that we have a
standard but
because i have unpacked that in my own
mind right because i used to be somebody
that wanted to try and fit the beauty
standard so bad when i was in high
school right i had very long black hair
it was down my back yeah um i made sure
i didn't put on any makeup because i
wanted to be naturally beautiful as
natural as possible you know like i did
all these little things to fit that and
then i realized
beauty is not just one way it's not like
a
i'll agree beauty is a combination it's
a holistic thing
but i think your look like brings you up
or down like okay
you have a type i have a type right and
i think if a guy fits that type he'll
maybe go up or down like one point but i
don't think you can like go from like a
five to ten i just think like and i
think you ask 99 of people who's more
attractive liza or beyonce they're gonna
say the same thing and like but this is
what i always say like whenever people
like don't really have a good argument
they always look for exceptions to the
rule and like the exception to the rules
that random country in africa yeah like
but just the fact that the exception
exists tells you that
it is really something that we create in
our own minds but even in africa well
from nigeria there was a demand for
ferrous uh women were more beautiful the
same thing in india they're
they love them because they got
influenced by instantly they got
influenced by people
they get colonized here and there you
know like but that again that brings it
back to history i've never felt more
attractive in my life than when i went
to india oh my god they would love you
they loved me they were asking for
pictures ever i was like me
it's like the same when i went to
lebanon
i went to lebanon with like and they
were like i was like the only black
person in lebanon it's like oh my god
mike tyson
okay
i gotta i gotta read some super chat so
um and bossy five pounds thank you a
mgtow um no pearl i was speaking to
jessica jessica's not here today um she
doesn't understand oh she's probably
jessica um she doesn't understand dowry
and a misunderstanding in that and
making judgments
which is bad behavior
okay
would you ever date a mortal woman who
refers to herself as a goddess does the
story of narcissus mean anything to you
um the i don't i don't get it i wouldn't
the that's like
the old greek story i think like
mythology yeah the dating game five five
dollars alexander 69 never mind ask them
what they think what do you think the
opposite sex would rate you
go around that side okay i'll start
first i think you've got to look at the
whole package
actually actually actually
oh actually girls and guys rate each
other let's do that instead
go you first
right through right there you can write
me and write them rate the girls just
sounds right
attractiveness just go one to ten
quick it says you can't think of it
surely
i won't i won't be offended i can take
it i can take it
what the hell is holistic about this
because it's not just about looks about
personality okay
okay
i'll give you a six sex yeah oh wait now
chess cut
eight
eight
go girls um
six eight
eight yeah sing that's uh that's what i
would have yeah six eight no girls rate
the guys
i already did this with him at least
she yeah right here
you go first you're the host
um
i hate giving sevens but i give you
seven okay
okay
five
sorry
it's okay bro
i give myself a five so i don't think i
don't think you should be that offended
ahead you guys i mean i feel the same
way as you go yeah yeah five five and
seven fair enough and that doesn't mean
you're not attractive it just means i'm
not
yeah she's trying to do completely
correct thing after the thing we could
take it we could take this okay okay
okay
it's okay percy is fine don't worry
about it
we aren't women francesca that was a dad
well i will give you a five and a half
fair enough and i had already given you
the eight so
i know you wanted to just hear me say it
again yeah because i want to piss you
off
okay 13.99 add amen dania full of
excuses um
is this diver dobry man again no no
full of excuses delusional mind and you
expose your thoughts madness but that's
your opinion
who are you talking to homeboy um five
don't be shy i send another super chat
run up her bank account five pounds
pearl can you ask
her name isn't jessica
can you ask jessica um
why
are you rude to the men when they're um
not rude to you but they're only
challenging your ideas
yeah jessica why because they had
consistently shown that they are okay
with interrupting me when i'm speaking
and if you didn't see that then i don't
know what to tell you
you interrupted them a couple times too
oh yeah absolutely but i made sure to
correct it as quickly as i could okay
but they consistently there goes that
double standard again
her name is jessica
damn y'all like me today don't you if
you spoke um if you
oh wait let me see
is it worth reading be
honest if it's not skipping um
i'm gonna skip that one
i bet most of y'all got half court
hairlines um okay
but let's see i think so i think
i will not
no they just basically said you're
attractive but don't talk like basically
that's too bad because i'm highly
opinionated no but i was like so they
think you're pretty right
so you
[Music]
i'm absolutely more than that i mean the
skill set that i have is [ __ ] wild
compared to the average person
so
that's why i said i fully know my value
and i can't but you
you did acknowledge that you were
aggressive though yes absolutely because
i know that like listen i was raised by
my father and he does have a little bit
more of an aggressive personality i was
not raised by my mother and even so my
mother is not like a super soft super
maternal kind of person
um
but i like the fact that i have this
personality because i know how to stand
my ground when necessary does it sub you
will it does absolutely because people
who truly care about me and understand
me know that i'm just standing up for
myself and i know how to speak
and articulate myself properly
people on the other hand get quickly
intimidated by that
because they don't have the same ability
to speak for themselves the way that i
do you know i would say i don't think
it's intimidation
i would say it is acknowledgment of the
fact that
they're not willing to engage with
aggressive behavior
and so a lot of the time so that is
intimidation no no no it's not it's
actually
yeah it's actually a wise
decision so it's like if somebody keeps
bringing aggressive behavior to to me
as a man i would say
i have to make a decision as to whether
or not i am going to deal with that and
i'll be like you know what nine times
out of ten yep especially if it comes to
a woman yeah i ain't willing to deal
with it yeah but here's the thing
on your side you might see that as me
being intimidated by yeah i'm just
saying listen i hear you're aggressive
and i can see you're aggressive but you
know what yeah go give that to you yeah
there isn't there is nothing i ain't got
time for there is a nation prophet that
says a man would rather be in the
wilderness than come home to a nagging
wife
nagging and yeah are not the same thing
i okay but that's not the case for me
i'm just going to
interpret it okay you guys don't
understand that we're talking about
things that i'm passionate about so of
course i'm going to be a little bit more
aggressive and a little bit more
passionate in the way that i carry
myself in this conversation however
when it comes to normal conversation i'm
chill like genuinely that's right
just be chilling i'm usually very calm
and i'm usually just very like i'm
excitable laughing
you could so you could change your tone
depending on the subject yes exactly i
don't think you're a bad person i just
think yeah you do have an aggressive
tone see the thing is growing up i heard
consistently that i was intimidating
usually from girls it was you were
intimidating because you were pretty and
you know yourself and from guys it was i
can't handle that
and unfortunately that's not my problem
i hate to say it but like if you can't
handle it that's fine
that that just means that you're not
meant to be around me
i can't handle aggressive women
because women are not supposed to be
aggressive and to be handled
if that makes sense like i don't think
we're supposed to be handled or
tolerated or anything like that right so
i would i so if you're an aggressive
woman i would literally in my own head
say okay cool she needs to go and be
with a man that's gonna be okay with
that i'm not okay with that because
you know i guess the bottom line for men
generally is that aggressive women
come with a lot of problems do you know
what i'm saying i'm not trying to like
i'm that i'm not trying to like sorry
i'm waiting for the silver lining
i'm just saying that
if you're aggressive and you but you say
if you're looking for a man or a partner
men generally do not want aggressive
women
you know that's
a very interesting statement because i
have dated quite a bit of men but in my
life but you haven't stayed with them
mm-hmm you haven't stayed with them i
haven't because probably you've probably
like
not not manipulated so it probably meant
that you
have been um
the man in the relationship no because i
have been authentically myself from
beginning to end in each release
i don't like that when people say i have
to be authentically myself if i said i
have to be authentically myself i'll
sleep with any attractive girl i see
that happening
yeah but i'm just saying that we have a
base nature but the whole point of it
you have stuff but my base nature is not
just sleeping with a bunch of people
that i find attractive though that's
your base nature so you're speaking for
yourself there's always a toxic shadow
side to each human being we all have a
dark side right that's what i'm just
saying i never said that i was only good
i said i was authentically myself but i
think his question is like what is
authentically yourself do you know what
i'm saying like so he's saying like i
don't know when you say that change the
way that i act in order to attract a
partner uh and a partner
just to end up changing up later on
yeah yeah
so i would say like
you know half the time that these
relationships didn't work it's either
that i wasn't emotionally mature enough
or i left for college or i have other
like i'm very i'm a very individualistic
kind of person
and especially within the last few years
like you know i graduated from my
bachelor's program i graduated from my
high school program like i was involved
in so many different jobs and activities
and social justice work
that sometimes relationships didn't
really fit in with my agenda
and i would just be like hey like you
know i realized that this is not my
priority right now i realize i have to
focus on myself i feel like i'm still
too young to get into a relationship or
like i'm too young to get a little too
involved in this relationship maybe it
could work later on but right now it
can't yeah right and plus you have to
bear in mind that things your mentality
probably will change in the next couple
of years or so so that's the other thing
that's why i kept making it clear that
in the relationships that i got cheated
on i was very young like
now like it's a whole i have a whole
different perspective on how
relationships should work and
generally a mature you know vision of it
however a lot of people our age are not
built for relationships i hate to say it
and all right well i think social media
has kind of ruined it because it makes
us think we have options options options
that's what you've been saying before
yeah yeah
candy
[Music]
and the thing is like the dating app
market is so powerful among us
and like you know how many matches do
you guys think you have on a dating app
i okay i can tell you this i don't know
this is terrible you were on tinder
though weren't you cassie nintendo i've
been on tinder in years
where did you mess with this guy this
dude
uh
i thought that was like two years ago
because it's lockdown
did you match him on tinder i can't
remember if it was tinder or hinge i
have i have been on like this yeah
last year even in the beginning of this
year but i just don't use them anymore
because i just if i'm honest i think i
think they're [ __ ]
i've never been on one well i was just
thinking like you have so many options
yeah
the point is like when you open a dating
app like all of us would probably have
like 100 like when i was about like this
is like terrible like genuinely terrible
but when i was about like 18 or 19
i had bought tinder gold just to see
like how many likes i had what was that
tinder gold
a subscription basically like it's like
a premium version of tinder so you can
see all the people that liked you
instead of it just being blurred out
like because there's an option where it
says like 99 plus likes
but they have you like pay for it so
that you could see who liked you
oh
yeah and then there's other options
where like even if you don't match the
person in the app you can message them
so you can still message them even if
you're not
connected at all you know they they
don't want to match with you hon like
don't don't message exactly i had that
happen to me several times when i still
had instagram like they they saw my
instagram in my bio and they'd still go
out of their way to message me even
though we didn't match but when i did
buy tinder gold i had about 8 500 likes
like that's nuts that's a lot of people
for me to sort through like
and i think out of the 8500 i only
matched about 800 of those people like i
sat down and i was like [ __ ] it like i
went through all of them yeah i did it
with my friends and we were like you
know what let's see what's going on here
and
it was probably the nuttiest thing i had
ever experienced with a dating app and i
will never do that again to be honest
because what the hell
but it's like
to think that i have that many options
right i think that there's that many
people that want to take the time i'm
not going through 800 people
you've never been on a dating app on
instagram really never why
because i don't need it okay fair enough
i'm a [ __ ] god
i mean personally to meet people in
person
and you have the whole person because
then you've got an
energy and if you meet a person in
person it's it's usually i say this it's
usually in a place that you both want to
be like a music event
yeah you already know you've got a
common interest on
social media and on the internet anyone
can be anyone no that's also because i
was in a 10-year relationship yeah
no i had no i prefer meeting people in
real life to be honest because on i've
never actually like
dated someone off of uh like a dating
app so clearly they don't work that well
one of my most successful relationships
was actually off bumble oh really yeah
like what's bamboo
another dating app
so the difference with bumble and tinder
is that
women have to message first and you're
matching the last 24 hours so you have
to hate bundles
no that's a no for me but i mean i think
i like that because it changes the
algorithm i like hinge i can i can put
on more filters
am i 65.
that's the whole problem especially with
instagram because everyone is so
accessible like i'm saying it goes back
to the kitten in a candy store it's like
a bigger mix yeah you know it's bad for
you but you're gonna try it and then
you're like oh i should have just stayed
with my original candy
for three months kirsty you know
we were going for a global pandemic
it's the only choice i had i think what
makes it harder is that our parents
obviously like at least for our
generation
our parents didn't grow up on social
media you know so they can't tell us how
to navigate it and how to properly carry
ourselves
because they barely understand it
themselves i can't wait till the next 50
years when we have the we see the fruits
of all the social media and they when
the social media generation have kids
my mom's only fans so many she said that
this generation is going to be the
generation of grandmas that have got
bbls and facetimes oh my god
in the next couple of years there may be
a backlash whereby we go back to the old
traditional model because they say this
i think i think what's happening though
i think there will be like uh a push to
go back to more
traditional
i think once like a certain amount of
gender like i feel like that actually
started happening already because like
remember when kylie jenner started
removing her lip fillers yeah well i
didn't like yeah people immediately were
like oh my god she did she did get back
with her baby daddy
you know men
men are more
men's role has been more traditional
kind of more consistently and the
women's role has been more
i don't know in this generation has been
a little bit less traditional
because we have to compete though
compete with who you're competing with
other women in order to get a partner
but there's also a lack i think of
masculine men and a lot of men that are
addicted to porn or corn yeah
and
so i think like the problem is like
on both ends like i do think there's a
lack of wives but i i think there's a
lack of husbands too i agree with you
because there's a lot of guys that are
just like all they want to do is play
video games and like but you know what
guys dude guys are generally like an
adaptor die type individual so it's like
for me sorry let me speak for myself so
if i i was in like a 10-year
relationship right
and
when you get back out into the market
you're like okay what's going on out
here do you know what i mean what's it
like and that's in the streets
you kind of realize that
things have changed
and you're you are going to have to
adapt to the market you can't bring your
old ways that you were like do you know
what i mean so
i think men have a
easier time adapting to the market yeah
whereas women
will hark on whoever they've created in
their head about themselves they'll
stick to that and they will stick to
that this is what it is yeah the ideal i
want this yes
never settle
but it's a problem
never
men say a little bloody time
that's what i'm saying no i just like i
think women settle a little bit more
no no actually you know what i think
it's kind of you know what's your
standard
i changed my mind on that because i know
that a lot of men end up in unhappy
marriages because they end up with the
woman that they know is gonna stick by
their side rather than the woman that
they want the whole time here's what i
think i feel like i've seen a lot of
them because we're practical yeah our
practical we're thinking long term but
then if you're not truly
caring for that person it's like why
would you put yourself duty we're going
back to duty
but why are you treating life like it's
a duty it is that's what makes it easier
why do you think
societies were built do you think
societies were built off like like some
kind of whimsical men
because people wanted to feel better
than other men knew they had a duty to
build the society that is why society
was built and protect you they knew this
meant men know this they know that you
know what i might not like it mm-hmm
right but it has to be done i don't i
don't think there's one i was yelling
everybody was barking at me but when
he's yelling nobody said a goddamn thing
because he's he's not because you you
kind of when you do it it's like
like you're mad almost like i don't
think he's mad he's just what i'm saying
but i'm not mad either okay i thought
you were earlier yeah yeah
i think more though it's like how do i
put it i'm just saying men understand
duty yes i i don't think that's because
duty was put on you by what
society but yourselves
who creates society who creates society
the people everyone of course so that's
what i'm saying like it's you can't you
can't blame society if we make up
society but also the people who have
control though like for example like the
christian church you know like they
controlled society for a long ass time
it's only within yeah yeah and there was
a reason for it because it brought
civilization because some something but
that's not what but look what before
that when christianity started to jump
into the government right like when they
were
but also one of the fruits of
christianity was that especially in
europe there were shell sacrifices
what is that i said that what child
sacrifices
yeah
in europe were obviously going through
the
evangelizing the germans and the
and they had also rituals child
sacrifices they put an end to that stuff
so
there's good and bad what happened to
them
i would agree that when you get into the
government and you get into power even
jesus said render to caesar what is
caesar to god what is god because you
can't legislate morality it doesn't work
hang on you can legislate morality but
when people try it doesn't work because
you're forcing it because there is a
morality is actually subjective it's not
objective right and that's why people
tend to think that morality is actually
objective it's not it depends on the
society in which you
that you're raised
there are basic rules that certain
things are wrong like incest rape murder
that's universal incest is wrong yep you
think incest is wrong yeah and you're a
christian yeah
so how it was normalized
this is going off a little bit okay so
when the flood happened to christianity
yes and there was noah yeah his three
sons yes
and their wives yes
that's eight people yep
eight people yeah
yeah do you think there was no incest
that was insects but then again it made
it became i'll tell you theologically
speaking it was made illegal when the
law of moses came
you did not hang on
you said before that incest is wrong
yeah i just showed you according to your
own stuff no i'm giving you that incest
is okay i'm giving you a chronology the
bible [ __ ] up a lot of times yeah so
i'm just giving you a question
there's a lot of beautiful i'm just
saying um
sorry i knew enough sorry
[Applause]
[Music]
like
i don't think there's a such thing as
settling i think everyone gets the best
that they can get
i think the best i think that they
deserve no you negotiate you negotiate
right yeah i really feel like you don't
get weak
that's like me that's like me okay
imagine imagine if i so i went to um a
school called elmhurst college okay
and i i didn't apply to harvard but if i
did i probably would have been rejected
so so but i don't go to elmhurst and say
wow i settled
no i got into elmer
and i feel like in dating like you get
what you deserve and if the places that
are accepting you
aren't aren't good right you probably
don't deserve the good ones but i think
settling is more of a mindset like it's
just dealing with what you think you can
deal with at the time because you don't
think you deserve better
i don't think that's a trap again you
know i think again i think you i will
one i think you attract what you are
yeah so i think if you keep dating
people that are toxic
and crazy like there's something about
you
there's also an adverse to that it also
could be someone that is like
they have a problem with wanting to fix
people constantly right
that is very common like there's always
like the narcissist versus like motherly
nurturing
i think i think that's a way that women
take
a lack of accountability
like genuinely because they put all the
blame on the other person oh he was the
narcissist i'm just the fixer and this
is coming from someone i've been in a
toxic relationship and i was toxic at
times so you can't you it takes two to
tango because like like i just don't
think you can put that all on the other
person yeah but people tend to do that
though yeah because they like to seem
like they were right all the time like
yeah nobody wants to look like the
villain yeah and it's only when you
fully understand yourself and know that
you're not perfect that you're like [ __ ]
it if i was the villain in your story's
need to accept that and give grace to
each other that's for relationships to
work yeah no grace
okay um so some super chats uh let's see
let me go up make sure i don't miss any
okay
um bowsey um men are not intimidated by
women we are bigger and stronger we just
haven't got time for rubbish
um jeremy wilkes um cheska my girl has a
phd she's as pretty as you
um a men daniel oh that was like that
was a whole comment yeah i was waiting
for something mean i'm not gonna lie to
you thank you thank you i appreciate
that um amen where are where where are
you and having traits your future
lifelong mate mate would like to see
from you do you see do you think people
are ready readying themselves dating oh
my god okay actually i'm going to answer
this question i'm trying to learn to
cook this year
i've been watching her i've been getting
no i've been getting better i i recently
got really good at drumsticks so
you'd be frying them yeah no no i mean
not not that good
have you given yourself food poisoning
anyway no
no i found out the other you need help
you could hit me up bro like a sort of
guy are you a good coach
gabby's been helping me a little bit
gabby taught me to cook salmon the other
day she saw my tick tock she's like you
need help teach you how to like
uh
bake it or like oh on the pan on the
phone okay okay it's because i i would
eat sushi so i'd always eat it like raw
so i was like i should circle but
because i would
use my favorite foods i love i make poke
bowls all the time
not all sushi is raw fish
not all sushi is raw fish phenomenal get
shrimp tempura and your life will change
outside what shrimp tempura very good
never heard of it okay guys but i think
i'm going to close out the show on that
already so if you guys want to put um
your clothes if any closing thoughts
that you have and where people can find
you
put me on the spot
i will say
love is a duty not a feeling unless they
become a will disregard the notion of
falling out of love
and
you know be the change you want to see
in the world and by the way my instagram
is in the 1983.
[Music]
i just say do what makes you happy
[Music]
right do what makes you happy
if you want to eat that pie eat that pie
if you don't want to eat that pie don't
eat at that point
do whatever you want as long as you
don't harm yourself for others right
exactly there are people that have their
fingers and many pies if that's what
makes you happy fine just don't hurt
anyone in the process um
that's some aleister crowley stuff
did you like it do what thou wilt
did you like it though it was good
wasn't it
okay there may be nothing he wasn't
he wasn't a cultist himself
for whatever reason my instagram is
j-s-y-k-a-g
um okay to all my haters out there
every breath i take without your
permission makes me stronger
um
to those of you that were nice to me
combative though i don't care um to
those of you that were sending love and
genuinely care about my opinion thank
you for caring um
like i said
just now
do what makes you happy as long as you
are not harming yourself or other people
or animals because
animals have feelings too
and
um no i used to be vegetarian for about
15 years though so you eat meat yes now
i do animals are homed
they were already dead before i could
get to them what you want me to do i'm
just saying but um if you want to follow
me on any social media my tick tock is
jessica delex c-h-e-s-k-a-d-e-l-i-c
uh
my closing thoughts uh
thank you paul for having for having us
um
it's been it's been a great podcast um
i've enjoyed interacting with everybody
everybody um my social medias are sarah
garvey s a r
s a space okay r a
garvey g a r v e y on all social medias
and also on instagram the black opinion
and also on twitter the black opinion
thank you guys for coming i couldn't i
couldn't do the show if people didn't
come so
so i appreciate it
i'm trying to buy a new camera right now
okay guys um like this video on your way
out it's free a like it's free thank you
so much for all the super chats guys
this is all going towards a new camera
you're going to get a close-up angle
soon so get excited
um don't forget to subscribe to the
channel again if you guys want to lose
weight our sponsor today is cooking with
chris customized meal plans you
literally just go to this nutritionist
you tell him what foods you already eat
okay and he makes a custom meal plan for
you